(dramatic music)
- Ladies and gentleman, boys and girls,
welcome to a very special episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I'm with the boys, all suited up,
gamer, gamer, and pro gamer right here.
- Normally, we are the boys,
but today, we are the men.
- The men.
- No, the gentlemen.
- The gentlemen.
- Exactly.
- I do wanna say, Joe, your
JoJo suit looks fantastic.
- Well, I wanna say, Connor,
your JoJo suit also looks good.
- No, you Garnt, he tried.
It's a suit but it's not a JoJo suit.
Garnt, I'm a little
disappointed, but it's fine.
- I did actually buy a JoJo suit,
but it came in and I
thought L size would be
big enough here,
but I forget that Japanese sizes are
like one size smaller than
the rest of the world.
- Their L size is basically
just a kid's size
everywhere else, isn't it?
- You're wearing the Bucciarati suit,
are you, Joey?
- I am wearing the Bucciarati suit.
- You look very fly.
- The full set up.
You're wearing the Kira suit.
- I am, the Yoshikage Kira suit,
got the full outfit.
- Is this out yet?
- It is out, it is out now,
you can buy it now.
- And it's a three-piece, so you got this,
I mean, I would show it all off,
but it'll--
- Unfortunately, our debut with the suits
on the "Trash Test" podcast
is not the JoJo episode.
- No.
- It's not.
- But we got something even better.
We've got the annual,
I guess it's gonna be the first
annual Trash Taste Awardw.
(everyone applauds)
Everybody clap.
- Yeah, and everyone clapped.
- And everyone clapped.
Congratulations.
- I think we've had enough
cringe-worthy moments, I'd say.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- We've had a lot of
moments in the last year.
I guess this is like literally
the fucking Obama meme
where we just congratulate
ourselves, right?
- I want to, frankly, yeah.
I want you.
- Why do I not do this on my main channel,
Is the real question.
But yeah, so to address
the elephant in the room,
this will technically be
the one year anniversary
of "Trash Taste",
'cause we've been doing this
for a whole year now.
- 'Cause this is episode 50.
- Episode 50, hopefully.
- And I mean, it's not episode 52,
'cause we've had two specials,
which is, frankly, amazing
that we could have fitted
already two specials in in
the current world climate.
- I'm just more shocked that
we've been doing this for a year now.
- God, it feels like-
- It's gone very fast.
- It feels like it's been like two months
and it's also felt like it's been
10 years at the same time.
- You know what as well,
I re watched a little bit
of the first "Trash
Taste" episode as well.
- Oh yeah.
- And I was like, "Wow,
it's so different."
- Really?
Are we all still like
awkward as fuck in that, or?
- Yeah, a little bit.
And we're all very considerate
of when each other are talking.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Like, "No, you," "No, you."
- Yeah, I mean, "Joey, go ahead.
"You tell it, you tell the story."
And now it's just like,
"Wait, hold on, I'm talking."
- "Everybody shut up, my time."
- We're also sitting
in the exact same spots
as the first episode as well.
- I suppose it fits actually,
I don't know if the counter is right,
'cause we swap every episode, but.
- The counter isn't correct,
but we are sitting in the same spots.
- Coincidentally, we're
all in the same spot
as the first episode.
- By complete coincidence.
- God, I wanna see a
comparison of this episode
with the first episode, like side by side.
That'd be crazy, but yeah.
So we asked you guys over on the subreddit
and also, was it on Twitter as well?
- Yeah, we asked Twitter as well.
- Basically, we asked you
guys around our social medias
to give us some awards to
give to ourselves essentially.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
That's the only way to
describe it, really.
We were just like,
- That is what we asked them.
- Yeah.
- We were just like,
"Hey, we gotta bunch of categories
for a bunch of different awards,
and it's all voted by you guys,
the 'Trash Taste' viewers."
So right now, us three have no idea.
- We don't know who's gonna win.
And by the way,
shout-out to our intern,
Ashley, who helped sort out these awards
and these beautiful, beautiful envelopes,
which we are going to be opening.
- Yeah.
- It's the "Oscars".
- This is as legit of an
awards show as we can get.
- This is the first time
we've given him a job
that's not "Get us coffee," so
he really pulled through with us for that.
- I shall open the wine.
Carry on, carry on talking.
- Yes.
- Please open the wine.
- And a shout-out to Ashley as well
for actually dressing up,
even though he's not
technically gonna come.
Do you wanna come on
camera quickly, Ashley?
- Yeah, come on, look at that.
- Look at that, look at that.
- We didn't even ask him to wear a suit,
he just rocked up with a suit
because he's a professional boy.
- Yeah, and then Meilyne shows
up with the tackiest way.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
With just your bog-standard T-shirt
and we're like, "Meilyne,
come on Meilyne."
- This is the Trash Taste Awards.
- Yeah, we were like,
"Meilyne, this is the
"Trash Taste Awards, so you
know what to do, right?"
- We might get more
viewership than the Oscars.
- Who knows?
- It's entirely possible.
- Well, I mean, that's not surprising,
to be honest.
But yeah, so I don't know.
I guess before we start,
and while Connors opening this,
I guess we can do like a
quick little reflection of the year.
- Oh, by the way, it's called Awardw
because in the original Reddit post,
Connor misspelled "Awards" and I guess
we're just rolling with it now.
It's the Trash Taste Awardws, not Awards.
- It's literally like the same root
as how like the word kek was invented.
It's just a mistype.
- Is that how kek was invented?
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- Oh no, no.
It was a how pwn was invented.
- Oh yeah, that's true, isn't it?
- Because the O and the P
is right next to each other
and then it became pwn.
Yeah, so there you go.
New meme, Awardw.
- So how many categories do we have today?
- 25, I believe, if I recall correctly.
- 25.
- 25 categories with, I
think, over 24,000 votes.
- How many votes did we
get for the survey, Ashley?
If you wanna put that up.
(wine cork pops)
- [Joey] There it is.
- Whoo!
- Wine time.
- The wine is open, there you go.
- All right, while we're waiting,
let's pour some wine.
- Wait, this is a Hokkaido wine, right?
- It is Hokkaido wine, yeah.
- Is that the one you bought?
- Yeah, this was like five months ago.
And we never drank, for some reason.
I think it was buried in the fridge,
even though I don't think we should put
wine in the fridge.
- We have like a bunch of alcohol,
that's just buried in the fridge.
- We have a lot of alcohol on standby
for a moment just like this.
- Finally, the wine glasses
fitting with the outfits-
- Exactly, right?
Look at us.
- Look at us, look at us.
If only I could recreate my,
(Garnt laughs)
I still can't do it.
I don't know what it was.
- Cheers.
- Oh, cheers boys.
- To a very successful year.
- Yes, absolutely.
- To an awesome year.
- [Ashley] I have the numbers.
- You have the number, Ashley?
- What are the numbers, Ashley?
- [Ashley] 24,210.
- 24,210 votes.
- Yeah, so 24,210 of you voted
for what we are going to present.
So if there's any salt,
you can just blame yourself.
(Joey laughs)
And if you didn't vote,
well, you kinda missed out.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Next year, next year.
Because yeah, as I said, this is probably,
I said "first annual" because hopefully,
as the years go by,
we can kind of keep doing this every year.
We can make it like a yearly tradition,
if you guys enjoy it, of course.
- Yeah, make it a chill little episode
where we just kinda.
- Reflect.
- Look back on.
- Yeah, we look back.
- Not a filler episode.
In the "Trash Taste" law,
this is not a filler episode.
- No, I've been looking
forward to this episode,
'cause like,
I've completely forgotten so many moments
that happened throughout the year
until we went through the
nominations that you sent.
And I was just like,
"Oh yeah, that did happen, didn't it?"
- Well, because if, you
know, simple maths, right?
Like, what?
It's 100 hours of us
talking for the past year.
That's 100 hours of content over the year,
if not including the specials.
- Yeah, it's like 120
minutes per episode, so.
- I don't really wanna know.
- It's like two hours an episode,
that's like a 100 hours, right?
Which is a lotta talking.
So no wonder we've forgotten some and,
to be honest, every time
a new episode goes up,
I genuinely don't remember
what we talked about.
- I don't remember the
fuck I talked about.
You guys know what we
talked about more than we do
most of the time.
- You guys know the law better than we do.
Definitely.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm excited to jump in,
to see what our categories are.
- Yeah.
- Sure, sure, sure.
Let's go towards our categories.
- So we asked you guys what
categories you'd like to see.
And based off that, we chose these 25.
There's quite a lot here,
as you can see on the screen.
- So just to read them off quickly.
So we've got Best Intro,
Hot take of the Year,
Best Out-of-Context Clip,
Screen Grab of the Year,
Most Degenerate Moment, Saltiest Moment,
Most Monkey Moment, I love that,
(Garnt laughs)
Best Story, Biggest Clown, Biggest Chad,
Best Nickname, Best
Complaining-About-America Moment,
because you know that's what
this podcast's all about.
- Of course, of course.
- We've got the Best Meme, Best Tangent,
Best Trash Taste Special Moment,
Best Drip, Laziest Drip,
which is, I thought I'd
never say that in my life,
Best Trash Taste Animated, Best Rant,
Catchphrase of the
Year, Guest of the Year,
Best Argument, Best Trash Taste Special,
Best Trash Taste Moment and
the Best Episode overall.
So lots to cover.
- I'm very excited to see what
the gamers out there chose.
- Yeah, right?
' Cause there's some of
them where I feel like
I think I know what's gonna win,
but there's some of them where I'm like,
"I genuinely have no idea."
- I think some of them
were pretty close as well.
- Yeah, because a lotta
the nominations, I guess,
were differing on how
we felt about it, right?
Like for one category,
there would have been one nomination
where I personally was like,
"Well, that's gonna win,"
and then you guys were like,
"No, no, it's this one."
So yeah, we don't know.
- And there were some categories where
I thought I knew the
winner of that nomination,
and then the actual nominations came in,
I'm just like,
"Oh, I completely forgot about this one.
"Oh, this is getting really hard now."
- Exactly, exactly.
So all we know is the actual nominations,
but we don't know at all who
the winners are gonna be.
- So I guess we.
- Without further ado, lets-
- We've got a lot to get through today,
so let's just jump right into it.
- So, let's start off
with the first category.
That, of course, being the Best Intro.
- [Garnt] Best Intro.
Just the tip.
- [Joey] Just the tip.
(Garnt laughs)
We asked Ashley to put these taglines
for each of the ones as well,
which I'm seeing for the first time.
- I didn't realize we
asked him to do that.
That's the first I've heard about this.
- "What is the Best Intro nominations?"
you're probably wondering.
Well, here they are.
Let's find out.
Oh God, Ashley, you just,
- (laughs) No.
- Ashley, you just spoiled the winner!
- All right.
- So the first one is
the "Salty Salmon Slices"
from Episode 04, I
don't remember this one.
- This is the first one that
I did which was different.
- Okay, okay, let's listen to this one.
- What's up, you salty salmon slices?
(Garnt laughs)
Welcome back to another episode
of the "Trash Taste" podcast.
- I'm sorry, what?
- You know how old it is
when you see how long my hair is in that.
- Oh yeah, 'cause this was
before you got the haircut.
- This was before I got the haircut.
- I remember you didn't, did you?
I don't think you told us
that you're just gonna
do a random introduction.
I think that's how it started, right?
For when you were hosting.
- Yeah, I was like,
- "Joey's dumb intros
"begin from this point onwards."
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, I think that's
where they started.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause most of these
are just Joey's intros.
- Most of these are mine.
- [Connor] All right, and Episode 14,
there's "Delicious Dickheads".
- I don't remember saying that.
What's up, you delicious dickheads?
Sorry, welcome back to another episode
of "Trash Taste" podcast.
- What was that?
Did you say "you delicious dickheads"?
- Yeah.
- I don't remember any of this.
- I don't remember this either.
Then we got "New PP," "Big PP Nation".
- "New PP Nation."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Where'd you get the "new" from?
- That's after the coup d'etat.
- Okay, of course, of course.
- What's up, big PP nation?
Welcome back to another episode.
- Oh no.
- I tried to say it with a
straight face, I'm sorry.
- I love how Joey just laughs to himself
about the dumb shit that he says.
- Because, like, no, I laughed at that one
because I was like, "Oh, this was
10 times funnier in my head."
(laughs)
The moment I said it out loud, I'm like-
- It was like a school kid saying, "69".
- The moment I said it out loud,
I was like, "This isn't funny."
(laughs)
But it made it on here somehow.
- And then, apparently, we
have Episode 40, 43 and 44.
So we had like three
apparently banger intros.
- [Joey] Yeah, wow.
- So this is the "Crazy Conbini Cunts"
which I wasn't very
happy, 'cause I was like,
"Good, Joey, you're gonna
get us demonetized."
- I think this episode is demonetized.
- This did get demonetized.
- So don't say it, bleep
it when you're done.
- Yeah.
- What's up you crazy conbini (beep)?
(Garnt laughs)
Welcome back to another episode.
That wasn't my idea.
That was Garnt's.
Yeah, that's right, it wasn't my idea.
Garnt told me to say it.
- Why would you believe him?
If Garnt told you to
put your hand in a fire,
would you do it?
- Yeah, Garnt quietly was like,
"You should say this at the beginning."
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- Then Joey's like John Travolta meme,
looking around the room,
"Why is it demonetized?"
- Yeah, why isn't it allowed on YouTube?
Come on.
- I'm so sorry.
- And then we got Episode 43:
"Connor Shits On His Phone".
- I don't remember that, man.
- Well, okay, we can already
tell this is not me.
So this is a Connor intro.
- I actually wash my
phone like once a week.
I don't like it.
It gets shit on it, I
don't really like it.
- [Meilyne] Gets shit on it?
(everyone laughs)
I shit on my phone, Meilyne.
- I don't remember that at all.
- I don't remember that either.
- I don't remember that.
That was like five, six weeks ago,
I don't fucking know.
- Yeah, right?
- I don't remember saying that.
- And then we got the
final one, Episode 44:
"Ladybeard Counts Us In".
- I remember this one.
- I don't.
- Out of every intro,
this one's the only one I remember.
- This is the weirdest intro by far.
- Play it, Ashley.
- Play the clip.
- And we're live in five, four, three.
- (laughs) Hello, everyone.
I love the edit on this,
how it just slowly fades into color.
It's slowly going live.
- I do not remember this at all.
- To be fair, the entire
"Ladybeard" episode
is a fever dream to me.
- It is.
I don't know how you handled
sitting next to him, right?
- I didn't.
Did you see how quiet
I was in that episode?
I didn't handle it.
- I just remember the "Ladybeard" episode
because it just took me back so much
about how much energy was
just radiating for the guy.
- It was that episode where I was like,
"Oh, we really must be like
low-energy on our episodes."
Either that, or this guy is just
absolutely insane.
- I think we were
an appropriate amount of energy.
I think Ladybeard has far too much energy
for any one human being to have.
- That's true.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I feel like maybe he's
siphoning everyone else's energy,
'cause you just feel tired around him.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Fuck,
"how do you do this?
"This is impressive."
- So which one do you
think is the winner, guys?
Let's give our-
- I mean,
our intern messed up.
- Let's pretend
that we didn't accidentally
get spoiled on it.
- Let's just talk about
our favorite one then,
I guess.
- Yeah, what's your
favorite one?
- I honestly don't have
a horse in this race.
This isn't a category that I feel
too passionate about.
(Joey laughs)
I'm gonna be honest with you guys.
This is one that I'm like, "You know,
"I don't really mind who wins this one."
- Yeah, look, I'm in most
of these horses and--
- Yeah, so what's your opinion, Joey?
- Yeah, but the thing is,
I'm most of these horses and yet,
I don't really care either. (laughs)
All of my intros is just
as dumb as the next.
- True, true.
- Well, I'm like five, so I'm like,
"'Big PP Nation', hilarious."
I hope that one wins.
- Yeah, I hope "Big PP Nation"
or "Salty Salmon Slices",
just 'cause it started the tradition.
- "Ladybeard", I guess.
I don't know, it was just weird.
It was like a fever dream.
- Joey, do you wanna-
- I have the cards right here.
- Who won, Joey?
Please let us know.
Build up the suspense.
- And the winner for the
Trash Taste Awardw Best Intro goes to
(drums playing)
"Big PP Nation".
(Garnt and Connor applaud)
We are 10-year-olds.
(everyone laughs)
- Wow, this is epic.
How many votes?
What was the percentage that it won by?
Do we know?
Or how many viewers
did it get of X amount?
- [Ashley] I'm trying to
bring up the stats now.
- I'm glad that we can confirm-
- It gives you a pie chart, though.
- [Ashley] Yeah, it's loading.
I think there's just too many responses.
- All right.
- I'm glad that we can confirm
that our audience are as
just mentally young as we are.
- Yeah, as mentally young as I am.
Laughing at my own big PP.
- Everyone's just immature,
which is why, I guess,
everyone loves talking about shit here.
- I wonder if it's a case of like,
people didn't really feel that strongly
about any particular intro,
and it had the funniest name.
I wonder if that happened.
'Cause if I saw this, I think I would see
"Salty Salmon Slices", I see "PP Nation?
"Okay."
- Yeah, "I awake."
(laughs)
Also, can I just say, opening
this up, feels so good.
- Oh, I'm excited.
- I look forward to my turn.
- Again, Ashley did these for us.
It looks so nice.
- That looks so good.
Yeah, shall we go to the next award then?
What is the next one?
- Let's go to the next one.
- Yeah, we do want the stats, yeah.
- What are the stats?
- [Ashley] It won with 22.6% of the vote.
- With 22.6% of the votes.
- And what was the next one?
What was the closest one?
- [Ashley] Closest one was "Ladybeard".
- Weird.
- Of course.
- [Ashley] 21.8%.
- Oh, wow.
- Wow, that's quite close.
- So it's a 1% difference.
- 1% difference.
- [Ashley] It's about 200 votes.
- About 200?
Wow, so "Big PP Nation" won by 200 votes.
- Rise up, big PP nation, rise up.
- Confirmed, the only thing
that can beat Ladybeard
is big PP nation.
- What's the difference?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- He's the leader of the big PP nation.
(everyone laughs)
All right, let's go to the next category.
Hot Take of the Year.
- Well, we're getting right into it now.
- Wow, this is getting out
the big guns already.
- I have a feeling that,
I can't remember what the nominations are,
even though we chose them,
I have a feeling that
most of these are Garnt,
'cause Garnt has just
the fucking stupidest takes, to be fair.
(Joey laughs)
He does.
Garnt is a very smart and wise man,
but then sometimes, Garnt says some-
- Sometimes he's like a
little too woke, you know?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Where it's like, "Where
did that come from?"
- I'm just too woke
when it comes to my food
opinions, apparently.
- I don't think it's woke,
I think it's broke, bro.
- Yeah, that's based as fuck, dude.
- We'll see, we'll see.
We will see, let's get on
to the nominations.
- What are the nominations,
Ashley?
- What are the nominations?
- [Joey] So the first one we have is
"Crusts are the worst part of the pizza
"and I don't eat them."
- [Connor] Let's play it, play the clip.
- Why does crust on pizza exist
and why does everyone pretend that it--
- It taste good.
- No it doesn't.
(everyone laughs)
- What a clown.
What a clown.
- I still stick to this
opinion to this day.
You know what?
I think, I remember
when I tweeted this out
and I think people who got canceled
get less hates than
when I tweeted this out.
I thought I knew what a hot take was
until I tweeted it out.
And I don't think I've had more replies
to a single tweet than this one.
- It was the first time I looked
at a tweet and I was like,
"This is why we needed a
dislike button." (laughs)
- It's just, frankly,
I hate to use it,
it's a cringe opinion.
- Yeah, it's cringe.
- I have some opinions where
I don't like something,
but I recognize that
I'm in the wrong still.
(Joey laughs)
And I think that you
should kinda, you know,
come to terms with it
that you're just wrong
and that you're--
- You know what?
It's after this episode
I've gotten so many secret messages-
- Fuck off.
- From like friends
who has just been like, "You know what?"
- Pizza Crust Anonymous.
- "I actually
kind of agree with you."
"You know what?"
- The Pizza Crust Resistance.
- I will be the pizza crust martyr
so that all of us who are,
the crustless gang can exist.
I will be the fucking martyr,
so that people will know that-
- Martyr?
Get over yourself.
(everyone laughs)
It's like, you need the crust, right?
So when you're eating,
you get a little break from just pizza.
As good as pizza is,
you get sick of eating
one noted flavor.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You dip in the garlic
and herb, the ranch,
whatever you do, you know?
It's fantastic.
- With ranch, it's game over.
- Okay, but that's the point, right?
If you need to have stuffed
crust or dipping sauce
or whatever, then that just means-
- [Joey] No, no, you
don't need dipping sauce.
It's a bonus.
- That's like saying like, "Oh,"
you could make the same argument,
"Why put a pizza on the bread?"
- Yeah, that's like saying,
"Why put anything on bread
"when you can just eat the bread?"
- Yeah, "If the bread is
such an inferior ingredient,
"why would you put
ingredients on top of it?"
Fuck off, Garnt, man.
- Because the crust
is just bread otherwise, right?
- Why would I not put any
viscous breakfast spreads on my bread
if I could just eat the bread?
- If the bread is great,
then why do you need stuffed crust?
- That's like saying,
"Why ever expand on base ingredients?"
- Are you trying to get another
nomination on this? (laughs)
- We'll see if they decide,
we'll see.
- I've chosen a hill to die on
and I'm dying on this hill,
to this day.
- Okay,
and a hill that I'm not proud of is
the next one, which is,
"I think steak is fucking mid."
Play the clip.
- God.
- I don't like steak.
- Oh my God, bro.
- I think steak is fucking mid.
- No, man.
- Okay.
- That was an opinion where,
you know when you hear something,
you have to double take.
You're like, "Wait, what?"
- Yeah, that was like the blinking meme.
- [Connor] Do you still
stand by that take?
- Okay, yes, in a sense.
But I say it's mid, look, okay,
I don't say steak is,
look, sounds like
backpedaling because it is.
(Garnt laughs)
Steak is mid.
I didn't say it was bad.
I'll still eat a steak, but it's not-
- Maybe it's inherently bad.
- But it's not my go-to.
- No one has ever been happy about
being called mid in any capacity.
- If I were to go out
and have like, all right,
let's have like a slab of
meat for a meal, right?
Like chicken, pork, beef, whatever.
However you cook it, whatever.
Steak for me is like
option number five or six.
- No, no, no.
Steak is like the top tier
if we're talking about a slab of meat.
- If money is no issue, it's steak.
- No, no, okay.
So after this episode went up,
I actually went to a really nice
steak place in Akihabara
where I was like, "All right,
it went up a few places."
- Backpedal of the year
for the next year Trash Taste Awards.
- Yeah, backpedal of the year.
You can include that.
- 'Cause nothing can beat
a good steak, and I remember
when I first heard this,
if my ears could vomit,
that's what they would
be doing right then.
- I think what this just proved
is that I just grew up
eating really mid steak.
- Probably.
- I probably didn't have
a nice steak.
I'm sorry, Father,
your steaks were pretty mid.
- And then, actually, it's great
'cause you also have
another shitty opinion.
- Oh yeah, this one.
"I think bacon is just not that great."
- Was this Joey?
- This is Joey.
- Oh, I thought it was you
both, I thought it was you.
- Play the clip, play the clip.
- Bacon is the cheapest part of the pig.
- Right, right.
- And it's shit.
And gammon's like the
actual meat--
- Bacon's the best part
of the pig, thank you very much.
- You've been fucking brainwashed, Garnt.
Oh, it's me?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
I thought it was Joey.
- No, I just agreed with you.
- Plot twist of the year,
'cause I remember I was on the
other side of this argument.
- Well, no, I agree that it's
not that great, to be fair.
- Yeah, it's not that great.
- It's fucking great.
Everyone loves bacon.
- Steak is above bacon for me. (laughs)
- It's like, "Wait, I
don't agree with that.
"Oh, wait, it's my opinion?
"I agree with that."
- Steak is above bacon,
because steak's one of the best meats,
but bacon is just like-
- No, no, no, steak is like in the middle
and bacon's below that.
- Oh my fucking God.
(Joey laughs)
Oh my God.
- Okay, I backpedaled the steak argument,
I stand by this bacon argument.
- Any other part of the pig is better.
Like any other part.
- Yeah.
Belly, shoulder.
- That's what I mean.
You remember like back in 2012
when it was like a personality trait
to say that you like bacon?
Do you remember that,
when that was a thing?
- It's the epic mealtime.
- Yeah, it was like, "Oh,
I like bacon, I'm quirky."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
"Okay, you like a widely
available, cheap product.
"Okay, cool."
- "I has cheeseburger?
"No, I has bacon cheeseburger."
- You know, I think it's been sold to us
a little too much by these corporations.
They put bacon on everything.
They make it seem like it's amazing.
It's not.
- It's really not.
- It is amazing.
- Okay, I feel sorry for you
that you're falling for
this corporate greed.
- Out of every part of
the pig, you cook bacon,
people know you're cooking bacon.
Why?
'Cause it smells fucking great.
It gets the taste buds going.
- It smells very good,
but the flavor is just-
- The flavor tastes like the smell.
- That's why they don't make
fucking bacon ramen, dude.
They make it out of the
other part of the pig
'cause it's way more flavorful, man.
- Way more flavorful.
- There's so much more richness going on.
Come on, Garnt, come on.
I'm not gonna argue
with a client like this.
- All right, let's look
at this last one, though,
which is, "To me, music
is just beeps and boops."
- At least two of these are mine, I guess.
- Play the clip.
- Yeah, two of these
are of Connor's, I guess.
- I think I actually am like
a caveman when it comes to music.
I'm like, "Ooh, the beeps and
the boops are very pleasing."
- Music goes, "Boop."
- Yeah, yeah.
Music goes "Whoo-ooh."
(Garnt laughs)
- I think this was the start
of the monkey brain meme, wasn't it?
- This was, this was.
- It was literally the,
"Wait, what?
"Is that just how
"your mind works?"
- Before this episode,
you were a man.
And then this episode,
you went down to monkey.
- Well, I mean, I also
got a lot of messages.
People were like, "Yeah, I totally
"understand what you mean."
They're like, "It's the same for me."
I felt like I met other monkey brethren.
- No, no, I know a few people-
- That's how I feel with
the pizza crust thing.
(Joey laughs)
- You met fellow, just like,
you know that meme where it's
the black outline of the
person, the brain caved in?
That's the crust one.
The monkey one is the
brain with the chair,
that guy that's sitting on his own brain.
(Garnt laughs)
Have you seen this one?
- No.
- You've seen this, you've seen it.
I'll show you later.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah, I mean, you
know, it is what it is.
I feel like this is just like,
I don't know if it's
like genetic or mental.
Whatever it is,
I literally cannot care about music.
- No, no, no.
I completely get this one because like,
for me, this isn't so much of a hot take,
'cause I know plenty of people like that.
It's just, I've never heard anyone else
describe it as beeps and boops. (laughs)
- Yeah, I would say, out of all of these,
this is not so much a
take, you know what I mean?
- Well, yeah, it's also,
'cause when I used to
try and explain it like,
"Yeah, I don't really
listen to the lyrics,"
like, "Oh, what, why?"
And then eventually, I just realized,
"Just say you like the fucking beeps
"and the boops of the music."
Everyone gets it.
I don't really think it's
a hot take, to be honest,
but you guys chose this.
- I mean, look, let's be real,
I probably already know what the winner of
this one is going to be.
I think it's a unanimous vote.
- I'd be very surprised if it's not
what I think it's going to be.
- Can we appreciate that three of these
came from one episode?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- Did it?
- And can we appreciate that
three of these are from,
no, there's three different episodes,
but three of them are food opinions.
- Oh shit, I thought they were
all from the same episode.
- No, actually, these are
all from different episodes.
- Yeah, they're all
from different episodes.
- Oh my God, I thought all of them
were from the food episode.
What was going on?
- But we just talk about food that often.
- We talk about food
way too much-
- And we have
differing opinions that often.
- Yeah, these are all
from different episodes.
- This episode is sponsored by Atsuko.
Gentlemen, what is that
drip you've got on there?
What are you wearing, Joey?
What are you wearing?
- I thought you'd never notice. (laughs)
Well, I'm wearing the Cowboy Bebop beanie,
as you can see.
- I'm wearing JoJo.
Don't pay attention to Joey.
Look at my drip.
- I'm also wearing JoJo.
- Nice drip, Garnt.
- Thank you.
- Good series.
- Nice drip.
- No, nice drip to you, Garnt.
- No, you.
Nice drip to you.
- Thank you to Atsuko and their
officially licensed apparel
and accessories from
all your favorite anime.
Meilyne, tell us what amazing
series Atsuko has to offer.
- [Meilyne] "Aggretsuko",
"Attack on Titan",
"Avatar", "Bananya", "Black Clover",
"Bleach", "Dr. Stone", a lot more.
- This is in alphabetical order.
We only just got to D, so you
can imagine how many series
they have, including JoJo.
- [Garnt] There are tons of new exclusives
not found anywhere else,
and there are new items every week.
- And gentlemen, you
boys know I love my drip.
I love my JoJo sweater.
- Of course.
- I'm never taking it off.
I'm gonna sleep in it.
I'm gonna bathe in it.
I'm gonna do everything in it.
And thank God that I got
10% off with the coupon code
TRASHTASTE at the checkout.
I am so goddamn happy!
- Everybody claps.
Plus, you can catch Atsuko online
or at both New York Comic Con
and Anime NYC later this year,
so keep your eyes peeled.
- So go to atsuko.com/trashtaste
or just click the link in the description
to get your drip today.
And don't forget to use coupon code
TRASHTASTE for 10% off.
- Hell, yeah.
Nice read, Garnt.
Nice ad read.
- Thank you very much.
- Back to the episode.
- Oh my God.
- Drip.
- All right, I guess let's
get to the announcement then.
I think this is me.
- Yeah, it'll be at the top of your pile.
(drums playing)
- Hot Take of the Year.
And the Trash Taste Hot Take of the Year
goes to--
- Not me, please, not me.
- Crust, crust, crust.
- Oh my God!
- "The music is just the
beeps and the boops."
- What?
- How did that win?
What the fuck?
- What an upset.
- How is this a hot take?
- What an absolute upset.
- What?
How is this a, what?
We were just saying.
Wait, what was the percentage?
- Not gonna lie,
I thought this was
gonna be the lowest one.
- Yeah, I thought so too.
Can we get the statistics,
please, of that?
- [Ashley] This won with 37.5%.
- 37.5% of the votes.
- Wait, what was the second place?
- [Ashley] Second place
was "Steak is fucking mid."
- What?
- Where did the pizza crust come?
- [Ashley] That was third.
- Oh my God.
- There's too many crustless motherfuckers
watching this show.
- I was right.
I was right.
Crustless gang rise up,
crustless gang rise up.
- What the fuck is wrong with our viewers?
Why would you not vote this clown
into oblivion?
- The resistance
was too large.
- Gentlemen, I have a dream
that one day-
- Fuck off.
- One day, you will not be judged
for your preference of food
before your love of
cuisine itself.
- Is this how Britannia felt
when Lelouch came?
- I have a dream
that one day, the crustless gang
and the crust gang,
and maybe even the only crust gang,
can sit on the same table in peace.
Thank you very much.
Crustless gang, rise up.
- The moment I go to a restaurant
and there is an option for crustless,
I am walking out.
I'm done.
I'm like, "What do you do with the crust?
"What happened?"
- I've never been so fucking
proud in my life right now.
- I'm so sad.
- This is how Britannia felt
when Lelouch came through, right?
(Garnt laughs)
He's like, "What?"
- How did I get that one?
- "They're so much bigger
"than I thought they were gonna be."
- Next category.
- Next category, fucking hell.
- I don't wanna see this shit anymore.
- All right, let's get
the next category up.
- I can't believe this.
- Best Out-of-Context Clip.
- This should be
an interesting one.
- So many good ones.
- You mean 50% of the subreddit is this.
- I think here's what we should do,
we should just play all the clips,
not say anything.
- Yeah, you're right.
- As you would experience
these, out of context.
- So these are the top four nominations
of Best Out-of-Context Clip.
Bang, bang, bang.
Bang, bang, bang, shh.
(everyone laughs)
- That one always makes me laugh.
- I love that one.
For the longest time, I didn't know
what episode that came from, though.
- No, I knew exactly what
episode that was from,
because I remember doing this, actually,
and I'm just like, "Wait, shit.
"I probably shouldn't have done that."
- It's a GIF, it's
immortalized as a GIF forever.
- Yeah, I knew it was gonna
be taken out of context.
- That's from the "Hentai" episode, right?
- Yeah, it was from the "Hentai" episode.
- Second one.
- That's the opposite way.
- Oh, the opposite way?
- I'd rather something up
my arse than down my throat.
(everyone laughs)
- There is no way you stand by that.
- I stand by it.
- Oh, fuck off.
- What I love about this clip
is that the way you say
it with such conviction.
- Yeah, it came outta nowhere like RKO.
- I stand by this.
- And this one is actually from one of the
"Trash Taste" streams which,
if you're not following
our third channel, then you would have-
- Trash Taste After Dark.
Subscribe.
- Probably missed this one.
- When I worked at fucking McDonald's,
that wasn't challenging.
And I'd go home and I'd be like,
"Right, now, I wanna be
fucking mentally challenged."
That sounds awful, saying that.
(everyone laughs)
It was a very poor choice of words.
Very, very poor choice of words.
- That was just like phrasing the clip.
- It was terrible phrasing.
- You could've said that in any way.
- I know, it was a
terrible choice of words
and it's haunted me to this day.
- And then this one,
oh, this might be my favorite.
- For fuck's sake.
- This, I think, to this day,
is still the highest rated-
- Why is this the
top-rated clip on Reddit?
- To be fair, it is very funny.
- Yeah, play it.
- But that one that just sticks out to you
that's just like, you meet somebody,
or I should specify,
that one convention story where somebody
was the biggest fucking asshole.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, because-
(everybody laughs)
- Get someone who looks at you
the way Garnt looks at the Corona.
- Do you remember why you were laughing?
- I do not remember this at all.
- What were you thinking about?
- I have no fucking clue.
Because the thing is, this
was like a clip where,
you know when you just do things
when someone else is talking
and you forget that you're on camera?
I have no idea what the fuck I was doing.
- You just kinda hope that
when you do something weird,
that it's on someone else.
- Yeah.
- Like the camera's on Joey.
- I do not remember what I was thinking.
I was thinking, "Yo, Sydney
was probably talking.
"No one's concentrating on me."
And if it wasn't for "Trash Taste",
then this would have never been filmed.
And it's now like the
highest rated post on Reddit.
Why?
I don't know why--
- 'Cause it's so funny.
- Good job, guys.
- There's so many other
good fucking clips and
fan art and everything.
And this, this is the
top clip of all time?
What?
- It's because the mind boggles, right?
It's like, "What was he thinking there?
"What was going on in his head?
"What made him laugh at that moment?"
- It's like the inside-out
meme where they go like,
"I wonder what he's thinking about."
- Yeah.
- Which one do you want to win, boys?
'Cause I personally,
I want the bang-bang-bang one.
- I really want the "Bang-bang-Bang" one
to win.
- I really love that one.
It literally encapsulates
"out-of-context" perfectly.
- I think I want the "I'd rather something
"up my arse than down my throat."
- That is a good one, that is a good one.
- Just because it was like such,
it came out of fucking nowhere
and that line hit like a truck.
I'm just like, "What the fuck?"
- Deadass, I don't even
remember saying that.
All right.
- Should we find out who won, gentlemen?
- All right, let's find out.
- The Trash Taste Awardw
Best Out-of-Context Clip goes to,
(drums playing)
"Garnt realizes he's drinking Corona".
- Yes!
Thank you, subreddit.
Thank you, we did it, subreddit.
- Why, why?
- And remember,
this is from Episode 20.
- Your upvotes were not put in vain.
- Get this off the top-rated.
Get it off.
Stop upvoting this, get this off.
- I wanna know how much,
did it win by a landslide?
- [Meilyne] 36%.
- 36%?
- 36%, that's pretty good.
What was the second place one?
- [Meilyne] "Garnt Without Context".
- "Garnt Without Context" was second.
But with how much of the vote?
- [Meilyne] 22.9.
- Oh, wow.
22.9% was the second best one with
Garnt's bang-bang-bang.
- So clearly, the subreddit
came through with this one.
- Well, Garnt clearly is just
the most out-of-context
person in "Trash Taste".
- Obviously.
Well done.
- Congratulations.
- Fuck's sake.
- Well done, Garnt.
- Congratulations.
- Well, I'd never had to deal
with this in my life before,
because I've never had a camera-
- 'Cause you're never on camera.
- 'Cause I had never had
the camera pointed to me,
so I didn't know I was doing this shit
and now, I'm just like,
"Man, I do a lot of weird
shit when I'm not thinking."
(Connor and Joey laugh)
You know what?
The day that something tops this
for the top-rated post of all time,
I'm actually gonna open
a bottle of champagne.
- I'm excited.
I wonder what could top this.
What could possibly top the wholesomeness
of Garnt just laughing at a Corona beer?
- I don't know, there's
a part of me that just
forever wants this to be at the top,
you know?
For as long as we do "Trash Taste".
- I don't want this to be immortalized.
All right, let's move
on to the next category.
Next category is Screen Grab of the Year.
- This is fucking hard.
- There's so many good ones.
- Yeah.
- This is one of the, like,
it could easily be like
a 15-nominee category.
There's so many good
ones and there's just,
every single week, I get a laugh
just seeing the stuff that we get.
But there are some ones that
stick out.
- Every time I go
onto the subreddit,
there's a new screenshot-
- Every episode.
- There's a new screenshot
that just makes me laugh.
- Here you go, guys, here's one.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- All right, let's look
at the nominations.
Oh yeah, of course.
(Connor laughs)
The classic "Connor Wine".
So we got "Connor Wine".
- That one's a fucking
immortalized classic.
- I've never been more like
the Barack-Obama-give-yourself-a-medal
meme,
because I can't recreate this.
And have you seen the GIF of it?
- No.
- The buildup to it
is even better.
- What episode is this from?
- The food video.
Episode 17.
- What were we describing,
or what were we talking about?
- I was joking about peasants
or something and being rich.
And I was like.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Some how-
- This is the perfect-
- And I can't recreate it.
No matter how much I try, like.
- It's got about seven different emotions
all packed into one.
- I can't recreate it.
This is why I wanna drink wine-
- It's just like the perfect emotion.
- Yeah.
And then we got me stirring the Umeshu,
this is from the stream.
That was from the stream right?
- It's just me fingering Pekora juice.
- Yeah, I completely forgot
about this screen grab
until it got nominated again.
- [Joey] And then we got
"Degenerates vs Normies".
- [Garnt] We can't see the entire one.
- [Connor] We'll have to show you
the full thing on screen right now.
- But it's pretty good.
It was used in a lot of memes.
And then we have,
I think Garnt's favorite, right?
- Yeah, this is also one
of my favorites where-
- Joey looking up the skirt
while me and Garnt are talking.
- This is like the equivalent
of the Corona bottle thing
where you didn't realize
you were on camera.
- Because you guys were talking about it
and I had it in my hand,
I was like, I was just curious,
I'm like, "Is she wearing pants?
"Let's find out."
- It was just such a cultured man moment.
"Yes, hello.
"I'm a fellow gentleman of culture."
- The man couldn't wait
until we were off camera.
He was like, "I have to look right now."
- Because you two were talking,
I thought it was this camera,
and then Mudan used the
fucking middle camera
where it's showing me doing this.
So that's all Mudan.
(Connor laughs)
And then, my favorite one is
"Garnt's Crooked Sip".
- [Connor] Why are you doing it like this?
- [Garnt] I don't know.
- [Connor] Who sips like this?
- I don't know.
- And your face
is utter disgust.
- I love this photo because
it's usually paired with
the Connor Wine photo.
- The gentleman versus the peasant.
- I feel like this is just yin and yang,
you know what I mean?
- Oh man, I don't know.
All of these are so good.
I wouldn't be upset if
any of these lost, but-
- I mean, I think the wine one
is probably the most iconic.
- Yeah.
- I feel like
that one might win.
- My personal favorite was
the "Degenerates vs Normies".
- I like that one a lot.
- Because it's just such a-
- Perfect.
- It's such a
perfect juxtaposition.
- Yeah.
- And I'm glad it was like
you can see that me and Sydney
were on the same wavelength.
I can't even remember this moment,
but I'm just like,
there's nothing that encapsulates
when me and Sydney hang out with these two
more than this one screen grab.
- Every time we hang out.
- There are some other
screen grabs I liked,
like we had the one
where the cycling special
where Garnt was cycling and
I'm at the window, smiling.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the one where me and Joey are sitting
in the chairs watching-
- Oh yeah With the green screen right?
- That got turned into a meme.
- Yeah made its rounds.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I also liked the one where like,
lady bead is like sharing the mic.
It's like whispering.
- That was pretty good.
- So many good ones.
But all right, there
can only be one winner
ladies and gentlemen.
- Screen grab of the year.
- Let's go a Trash Taste awardw
screen grab of the year goes to
(drums playing)
the Connor wine face.
(Garnt and Connor) Yes!
- I can't redo it.
- It's classic.
- Did this one win by a lot?
I'm curious.
- I assume this one's going
to win by a landslide.
- [Ashley] 50.4%
(everyone laughs)
- Wait, what was the second place?
- [Ashley] Second place
was the one with Sydney-
(everyone) Oh, okay.
- [Ashley] with 24.1% up-vote.
- Very good.
- Yeah I mean, there was no beating this.
- I mean, this was the
iconic one of the year
that was I think used the most.
- Yeah.
- We need like one of
those North Korean esque,
shrine pictures of this-
- Just like that.
- In the office.
- An army needs to walk past this photo.
(everyone laughs)
To like pay tribute.
- Pay tribute.
(everyone laughs)
- Pay tribute to the wine meme.
- This is probably the
one, there are a few,
some of them where I was like,
I'm pretty sure I know-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There are actually many where I think
I know what's wrong.
- No, no.
- This was one of them just because
I've seen this picture so many times.
- When I tweet, I just get
like five replies of this.
- Its the perfect reaction.
- Yeah-
- And I'm not even mad,
I'm like, you know what
I like seeing it is that vain of me?
I don't care, It's funny.
- No If that was me-
- It's just a great fucking face.
- I feel like I don't even
see me when I look at it.
I just see a funny ass reaction.
I don't know why.
- It's just like the perfect
twitch emote, you know?
- It's one of my twitch emotes.
- All right, let's move
on to the next category.
Most degenerative moment.
- Oh God, God knows-
- This was one of the hardest categories
to pick from I think.
- Yeah, there's just so many.
- We're pretty fucking
degenerate on this podcast.
- Look at us, look at us.
- Degenerates here.
- Men of culture.
- All right, let's look at the nominees.
All right we got-
- [Garnt] Meilyne's 3x3 and Body Pillows
- This is a true degenerate moment.
- God, that just like,
I was like so impressed
by this three by three
because we didn't, we
didn't share it beforehand.
And I didn't know how hard
Meilyne was going to go.
- I love how much of this
clip exploded as well.
The clip is like 300,000
views or something like that.
It's actually, it's actually a ridiculous.
Meilyn, you did it, Meilyn.
- 'Cause I think it just shattered.
Like, everyone had this
image of Meilyn being like,
okay, she's prim and proper,
she brought the boys together
and then she reveals like this,
she drops this fucking bombshell.
- I'm actually a degenerate.
Are these videos or?
- [Ashley] Videos.
- Oh shit Play it.
- Play them up.
- "Monster", "From the new world",
"Uta no prince Sama",
"Jojo", "Vampire Night,
"Golden Kamuy", "Story of Saiunkoku",
"Ceres", and "Hakuouki Shinsengum".
- What I remember about
this moment is when
Meilyn talked about her body pillows-
- Yeah.
- It's like how many,
there's like 50 or something?
- And then she put scents on them.
- I think it was the first time
where all three of us were
just like gobsmacked that we just,
that was like just a five second silence
where we were just like,
"what the fuck did we just hear?"
- Isn't there that
picture of me that's like.
(everyone laughs)
That's like making its
rounds from this moment.
- And then obviously we have the next one,
which is, oh-
- this is
- Just play the clip.
- Yeah.
Just play the clip.
- And it was just like this giant fleshy,
It's this fleshy giant
roll of a bunch of pussies.
(everyone laughs)
- But that's all you need to know.
That's that's all the context you need.
- (mumbles) That's the free degenerate.
- Never been on Sydsnap
channel, there you go.
That was a five second
sales pitch of her channel.
- Oh God then Joey-
- And then the next one is, this one is,
let's just play it.
Let's just play it, let's just play it.
I really like A:
I really like elf girls
and I really like tan girls.
- Dude, dark skin elf girls-
- Dark skin elf's-
- Dark skin, elf girls, man.
- Replace every hentai
with a dark skin elf.
(Joey laughs)
I stand by this.
- I mean fair enough.
I feel like this clip
went very fair on Joey.
This could have been one way where
he's talking about gang bang.
Got the one where he was just being nice.
- This is the fucking like predator meme
with like the muscly
guys like hand shaking
like Garnt and I are doing
that under the table right now.
That was such a fun argument.
I think the Hentai episode
was definitely like one of
the most fun to film as like a,
as like a host.
And I remember filming this
and just losing fucking my mind.
- This is a very good-
- And then there's another one actually
from that same episode.
- Oh yeah.
- These are from the Hentai episode.
- Oh yeah, it is.
Yeah, yeah 'cause we got
like a Steve Handjobs.
- All right, let's play the next one.
- Play the next one.
- How does anyone get on to get off
to this and like 2020?
- Okay, well, first of all,
I don't really care about like animation.
It's more like-
- Yeah, no shit.
- Listen, I also saw a
funny thing the other day
about Mother knows Breast,
someone posted on the subreddit.
They were like, "oh,
someone bought a copy of
"Mother Knows Breast",
they should tell Connor so
they can get a physical copy."
And it was like my picture
of my physical copy.
- [Joey] Really?
- "Mother Knows Breast",
I think they grabbed off Google images.
I was like, it's mine.
I own the physical copy.
- I should let you know
about your own physical copy.
(everyone laughs)
- Connor, hey Connor should
get in touch with this guy.
- Yeah.
- He owns a physical copy.
- It's like oh really?
All right.
- Play the next one.
- This one's good out of context.
It puts me off,
so that's why I Chromecast it.
- I'm just going to
message you every hour now
just hoping that I'll catch you.
- That's why, that's why
I Chromecast it to my TV.
- Listen I stand by it's convenient.
- Do you still do that?
- What you mean? Like
I changed my ways after
this episode came out.
- Well, I don't know man.
- How you can tell someone
lives by themselves-
- Yeah right.
- Living with a significant other, right?
- Listen I would like my partner to
understand what I mean to do.
- Just be like darling,
stay in the living room
for twenty minutes.
I have business.
- All right, and then this last one
oh man, this is from the figurine episode.
- Oh, episode 4, wow.
- Play the clip.
- I remember it being way over my budget.
- How much?
- This was 170.00 dollars.
- Garnt what the fuck?
- See we say degenerative moment,
this Garnt got the W.
- (mumbles) I was just,
cause I remember you both
were playing the game and I'm just like,
I just want to see titty
and it somehow ended up,
she fucking solo carried
my performance there.
- The titties won, man.
The titties prevailed.
- Exactly.
- Oh man, this is hard.
This is so hard.
- Any of them I'm fine with
any of them winning this one.
- Yeah, really, honestly,
these are all just as degenerate.
- I can't pick.
I'm glad I didn't have to pick-
- All I hope is that,
at least one of the ones from
the Hentai episode one, right?
'Cause that would be somatic.
- I think that would somatic.
All right.
The winner of the most
degenerates moment is-
- Please not me, please not me.
(Drums playing)
- Sydsnap pussy of the round table!
(everyone claps)
- Oh wow.
- Relatively speaking.
- Understandable.
- That's about as degenerate as it gets.
- Right, understandable.
- Well, she just earned the
title of queen of degeneracy.
Congratulations.
- She'll lead by her name.
- Was it a landslide?
Was it close?
What are the-
- How close was this?
- [Ashley] This was, she won with 32.3%.
- Oh wow, this is quite a bit.
- With six nominations.
- Six nominations.
- [Ashley] Second place
was the orc gang bang.
- The orc gang bang?
- [Ashley] With 30.2%.
- Pretty comfortable margin.
- Pretty comfortable margin yeah.
- Yeah, wow, congratulations.
- Congratulations Sydney.
- There you go Sydney you can,
hold on to the title loud and proud now.
- No doubt we'll be
getting a tweet about this.
- Live tweet on this
entire episode from Sydney.
- What is the next category, actually?
- Saltiest moment.
- There is many.
- The amount of sodium
this year was very high.
- I actually don't even again,
I forgot what the nominations were.
There's so many.
I get angry about everything,
So it could be frankly anything.
- I mean every upset we
rant about something-
- Exactly.
- What all the nominations Ashley?
Please do let us know.
- Connor after losing at cycling!
Play the clip.
- Play the clip.
- We'll cut to when we're not dead.
- Yeah, Bye!
- Boys, I have to ask one question,
how does it feel to be a cheater?
A dirty little cheater!
- I feel good.
- I hate how this actually turned into
like a full on argument.
- Yeah.
- Amongst the viewers,
even though I didn't even cheat,
people were saying I did, I can't believe.
- Right, right.
Keep telling yourself-
- I am still salty.
- You can see, you can see the salt-
- Radiate to this day.
We didn't cheat either,
we just played the game like differently.
- Okay, I don't want to get into this,
I don't want to get into this!
Give me the fucking-
- Oh, this next one is from
one of the live streams actually.
- No actually three of these.
- Oh yeah, three of these
are from the live stream.
- None of these are from normal episodes.
- Three of these are from live streams.
- These are all from
live streams specials.
- I guess this is just like the
"Trash tastes after dark Highlight".
- Catch-up on "Trash taste after Dark".
There's only three episodes out right now.
- Also, follow us on twitch,
if you wanna catch these live.
- But play the second one,
this is from the
"CrunchyRoll anime Awards".
- [Narrator On TV]
"Kaguya-sama: Love Is War".
(Joey laughs)
- [Garnt] I'm not okay, I'm not okay.
I'm not dissing Kaguya.
But I am not. Okay.
- I'm still not okay about this.
I like the fact that Connor
tried to like justify this.
- You know, we were sponsored.
I was, I dunno, (mumbles)
trying to keep the ball rolling.
- Yeah, I can understand
that we were sponsored
and I knew that's what
you were trying to do,
And I'm just like,
"I cannot stop visible
disappointment right now".
- You can do it, and then I'll like,
I'll like save, you know?
- There's also, a great
moment in that clip
from the live stream right?
It's like Jerry was saying something,
I was like,
"shut the fuck up Jerry
don't say anything".
- Oh yeah.
- I remember this also gave like a
really good out of
context screenshot when it
was just like my visible disappointment
and Joey just looking at me,
like fucking losing it.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- You know that could
easily green screen guys.
- I honestly did not even care,
I was just loving the fact that
Garnt was being so salty.
But this next one
when Wales doesn't have the best flag.
- We have the coolest flag.
- Yeah.
- It's just straight up.
Like you can't deny that, right?
England flag?
Boring.
Wales flag, fucking dragon.
Like shits bad-ass
and there's a cool story behind that.
- I remember,
this was the first live
stream as well wasn't?
- I don't know if this
counts as a salty moment,
as much as it was just yet another
trash tastes argument.
- Well I was quite salty about it.
- This clip, is like kind
of the beginning of it.
And then Connor ranted about
it for about 45 minutes.
Just being like, no guys, no, no.
- Yeah, it was, the
folks at the live stream.
- That's right,
because we also went on to like
top 10 flags in the world
and Wales was on none of them.
- Play the last clip.
- Yeah play the last one,
called a Karen.
- Did Joey wake up and
choose to be a Karen?
(Connor and Garnt laugh)
- What do you mean?
I don't know what that means,
but that made me laugh.
- Joey got so angry about this one.
- No, I didn't, it wasn't
even me being angry, honestly.
I get a lot.
Let me, let me reiterate all right?
(everyone laughs)
- I love this.
- I wasn't even angry-
- Go on Joey.
- Dead ass I wasn't even salty,
I just was confused,
'cause it came out of nowhere.
- I okay-
- It was like one person
in the chat said it.
You picked it up and everyone was like-
- At the time I remember the context,
but now I totally forgot.
- Yeah, right?
- I can't remember the context.
- I don't even know what I said
that turned me into a Karen,
but apparently I became a Karen.
- And then you'd get annoyed
'cause you didn't know why.
- I got annoyed because I
was like, explain yourself.
There's no explanation.
- Twitch chat, explain yourself.
- All right lets find out.
- I fucking love that moment.
- Anyway, who'd you guys want to win?
- Oh God, any of these could win honestly-
- Honestly, I want the Joey being a Karen.
- I think the saltiest moment is
actually Connor losing at cycling.
- Well, the one that still
makes me laugh to this day-
- Is the Karen one.
(everyone laughs)
I wouldn't be surprised.
- Every time we mentioned this-
- It's like, why?
- All right, gamers let's find out
who won the Trash Taste
Saltiest Moment of the Year.
(drum roll)
All right, ready gamers?
Oh,
it is the Connor when Wales
doesn't have the best flag.
- Wow.
- Wow, really?
- I am really shocked
by these choices so far.
- I am shocked!
- That's an offset.
- I would have put that at number four.
- Yeah, I would have put
that as number four as well.
- We clearly don't know our audience.
What was the results?
Can we get the results?
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] 36.6%.
- 36.6%?
- What was second place?
- [Ashley] Second was
Connor losing at cycling.
- Oh wow.
- I'm just the saltiest
trash taste member.
- Yeah, clearly-
- Which is fair enough.
- Wow, so what we prefer and what our
audience prefer clearly is very different.
- I mean, I thought the
cycling one was going to win.
- I thought the cycling one was gonna win.
- I was very, very salty.
- I'm surprised that there are that many
"Trash taste after Dark" viewers.
- I wonder if this might be
a reoccurring theme where,
you know, perhaps some
recency with the staff
might play into the voting, maybe.
But the Joeys a Karen
is a more recent one.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, but the Wales one was
the first live stream.
So that was ages ago.
- I think no one's really talked about it
on the subreddit or even
mentioned that moment.
- I mean all good moments.
- It's very interesting we're
getting a lot of like data-
- Right?
- About you guys there.
- Let's go on to the next one,
number seven are we?
- I think so.
- Yeah we're on number
seven is the next one.
Next category is-
(all) The most monkey moment.
- Well, I might have a bit
of an advantage in this one.
- This is like saying best
Quentin Tarantino movie
and they're all Quentin Tarantino movies.
It's like of course,
who else is there gonna be?
(everyone laughs)
- Connor, Connor, do you want to read out
the nominations for this one?
Why don't you read out the nominations?
- I think only two of are me.
I think some of them
are very funny actually.
- Really?
- I think because there are some very
monkey moments of you fellas.
- Okay, let's find out.
- It would be like the
plot twists of the year
if you didn't win this award.
- Well, I actually think
there's a good chance
that someone else could win this one.
- All right.
- Let's look at the nominations.
- Let's have a look, shall we?
- Oh okay, Connor breaking a bike,
play the clip.
- Look at the view!
Oh shit! (laughs)
Did you get that on camera?
- I'm surprised you didn't
fucking fall on your ass.
- Monkey has a good balance.
- I'm surprised it wasn't
the you breaking two cars,
'cause I feel like
you'd breaking two cars,
is even more monkey than
just breaking a single bike.
- True, true, true.
- Oh yeah.
- This was pretty monkey-
- This could be a winner.
Joey's unused GPU.
- This is easily my most monkeys moment.
Play the clip.
- Joey, for five years used to have
a 980 graphics card that was plugged in,
powered and never used it.
- He was still using a
Intel CPU graphics card.
- I completely forgot about that.
Yeah, that is pretty monkey actually.
- Don't worry, audience,
I properly plugged it in now.
- No, I plugged it.
- Connor made sure.
Connor literally held his hand
and was like, "Joey, do this."
- This is where you plug it in.
I was like, "okay, father."
- Me skipping cut scenes.
- Connor skipping cut scenes in games.
- I stand by this.
- Let's play this clip.
- I don't know what
happened to me in the womb,
but like I can't pay
attention to story in games.
The moment story comes
any video game, I'm like,
"where's the skip button, where's it?"
- Really?
- It's true, it's true.
- As, as Nikki Jakey says,
you have that "goopy goblin gamer brain."
- I do man, I can't pay
attention to cut scenes.
It's just what it is.
- Text and dialogue and listening.
- Reading, you know?
- There's no gameplay loop,
in pressing "A" the button.
- I was, Mudan asked
me to make a thumbnail
for my second channel,
and he was like,
"can you just like grab a
few books for the thumbnail?"
I was like, "I don't own any books."
And I was like, he was like,
"you don't like Manga?"
I was like, "no, I don't have any books."
I literally don't have any books.
- Yeah, Connor's house and my house
is the literal opposite.
- Not even like Manga volumes?
- I own one single Manga book.
And that's just for show-
- And that's the extent.
- That's for aesthetics.
- Yeah, that's that book
on the coffee table.
- I literally don't own any,
I don't read books like straight up.
That is what it is.
Monkey.
I admit that's monkey.
I have a feeling that, you know,
because here there's three Connor moments,
the vote could be split between three-
- [Joey] Could be.
- And giving Joey the edge of being
the most monkey brain maybe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But there's also another one
of Ladybeard being a monkey.
- Ladybeard is, and I say this
in the nicest way possible:
is one of the hardest people to work with.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, shit!
- To this day Ladybeard is the only guest
that has like done permanent
damage to our sets.
- He dented our fucking
sliver play button.
- He dented our play button.
And I remember afterwards he still like
was moving around so much and it was
just like giving me so much anxiety
whenever I see him move back and forth.
You can tell he was like
a proper pro wrestler.
Like he was proper manhandling that mic.
- That man just throws his
massive body weight around.
- 'Cause when we told him
before the podcast started
that like,
you need to have this mic up to your face,
He was like, "got it."
Just fucking grabbed it like this
and was like, "okay, so!"
- We normally have to
turn guests microphone up,
'cause their not used to it,
but we actually have to turn his down.
(Joey laughs)
Which is a first,
I think it will be a last honestly.
- Yeah, the man had a
better handle of that mic
then I do with my life.
It was like, it was impressive, honestly.
- All right, and then this last one is an
absolute classic trash taste moment.
Play the clip.
- Sometimes if I'm like
real angry some days,
or I wake up and I'm upset,
I'll just go in the mirror
and I'll be like, "come on!"
(everyone laughs)
- I still do that, I still do that.
Sometimes you got to do it.
My neighbors probably don't appreciate it.
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- Frankly, they probably
in a worse mood than me,
so who cares?
- It's just like,
it's sometimes I just
hear some lines from you
and it's your like brain
is just like literally
that monkey picture that's
just like neuron activation.
- That is.
- That it's like sometimes
when I see some of the stuff you do,
it's just that little picture.
- All right, so which one do
you think is going to win guys?
I have a feeling it's going
to be one of Connor's,
but I secretly hope me with the GPU wins.
- Honestly?
On paper it's the GPU is the most monkey.
- Right.
Out of every one of these single moments,
it's the GPU one.
- I think I embody monkey,
the dumbest moment.
- The standout out one, right?
- In my opinion.
- It's the juxtaposition.
- Again, like I said,
I think because people who
might think I'm the most monkey,
they might spread their votes-
- Yeah.
- I think there's a chance (mumbles)-
- Yeah, 'cause these ones
are just like monkey moments.
But I think like,
you literally regressed in
evolution when you did this Joey.
(Joey laughs)
- I can hear "Guts" theme playing
when I opened up your PC.
- Yeah, this is like momentary monkey,
this is five years monkey.
- All right.
- All right, I have the
winner right here though.
Let's find out.
Trash taste awardw most
monkey moment goes to:
(drums play)
Joeys unused GPU.
(everyone laughs)
- Let's go!
- You know what?
I ain't even mad, I ain't even mad.
- The upsets, the upsets.
- The upset.
- Fantastic, great moves.
- Wow, was this a landslide?
- [Ashley] Not really, 31.2%.
- 31.2%?
Okay.
- What came last?
- Well, what came next?
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] What came next was
Connor skipping cutscenes.
- Connor skipping cutscenes?
- And then?
- [Ashley] Coming last was Ladybeard.
- Oh yes see-
- Oh yeah.
- My theory Was right,
that all the monkey
moments were spread out
- Yeah, and then Ladybeard,
that was just one monkey moment
out of a two-and-a-half
hour monkey episode.
- Yeah.
- Man, I'm glad you won that one.
- I'll take the dog.
- I'm really happy you on that one.
- I'm glad you won that one as well.
- This is the most honorable
dishonorable mention.
- I mean, it was just like,
I'd say it's an upset,
but it was also well-deserved.
- Well-deserved, well-deserved.
Well done me,
give myself a metal for that one.
- What's the next category, gentlemen?
- Lets find out.
- [Garnt] Let us find out.
- [Joey] Best story.
Oh man, there's so many great
stories that we've told.
Give me some more wine there, buddy.
- I'll get you all more wine.
- I can't even remember
half the stories we tell.
- We all just come to the
table with some great stories,
what can I say?
That's why you guys watch the episodes,
hopefully, right?
- I know, I think it's the stories.
It was the stories that
first distinguished
"Trash Taste" from,
like an anime podcast and
everyone was just like,
"wait, we don't give a shit
about you talking about anime,
just give us more stories."
- Just give us more stories.
- My parents sometimes
message me like Connor,
you got that one detail wrong-
- Yeah.
- I guess it doesn't matter.
- I get that all the time.
- It's theatrics-
- Yeah.
- It doesn't matter.
- I get that from my parents as well.
- They always remember different.
But let's look at the
nominees for this one.
- Yeah.
- All right so,
(everyone) Joey came out to his friends.
- [Connor] Oh, I love this.
Just play it, just play it.
- [Joey] Let's play the clip.
- [Connor] This is so, so good.
I don't want context.
- That was the point where
we basically him and I,
we found out that we
found out from each other
that we're into those kinds of shows.
- We're just into each other.
Like it keeps getting
worse and worse though.
- I didn't even do that
on purpose, I was like,
"how do I structure this story?"
- Like cause I was like,
I remembered like losing it
when you were telling the story,
because I was like,
"there's no way he is not
doing this on purpose, right?"
And it just kept getting worse and worse
it was not like the, if,
it wasn't the award for
best out of context, moment-
- Yeah.
- This was just the best
out of context like, story.
Like everything like this
encapsulates everything
about out of-context.
It's fucking amazing.
That one little clip doesn't
do this entire story justice.
- Yeah.
- Go watch the full clip
on the highlights channel.
But what's the next one?
Garnt drew a huge dong
during his job interview.
Play the clip.
- My career is on the line here,
I just want to get a job!
What could you possibly be laughing at?
And then I look at what I drawn.
I've drawn a penis.
(Joey laughs)
- I love that clip.
That clip is so good.
- That's such a good story.
- Oh my God.
I still like,
I remember telling that story
and my parents didn't know
that that happened
during my job interview,
so they found out that that was the reason
I got rejected from my first job interview
from watching "Trash tastes."
- Hell yeah.
- A very stern text
from your mom followed.
- I was about to say,
keep the fans coming you
gotta get a tease in.
- And then this one just
inspired an entire special,
didn't it?
Play The clip, play the clip.
- How I ended up playing
professional chess
is weird to begin with
because I never like played it much
I just liked video games alone.
- Yeah, I mean, it was,
it was a very long story.
I think this was less
of like a funny story,
more of just like,
this is like a character
development story, right?
- Yeah, that was like one of the clips
I feel that you're like,
"whoa, what the fuck?"
- Yeah.
- I was like, "well, what the fuck"?
- Yeah, 'cause I remember you
telling that story to me beforehand
and I was just like, "you've
got to tell this somewhere."
- Yeah, right?
- This is an amazing fucking story.
- And I'm glad I got to tell that
and I'm glad that people
really enjoyed it.
Like I remember when that clip came out,
or the episode came out,
people we're like, "whoa",
everybody went, ran with it.
- I remember "Chess.com"
hit us up after that-
- Yeah.
- And then it tied the chess tournament.
- [Garnt] Throwing poop at-
- [Joey] This is such a great story,
I love story.
- Out of so many poop
stories that we've told
on this podcast,
I think this is probably
my favorite poop story.
- So disgusting.
- Play the clip.
- Getting that shit,
putting it in a Halloween, pumpkin, sorry.
And throwing the pumpkin at
one of my friend's windows
and then exploded.
- That's one of those
stories where it's like
this story would have
been a hundred times funny
if you were there.
- Yeah.
- But it's still hilarious.
- It's hilarious.
- Well it's like disgusting in the moment.
But then the moment you have
to tell it the first time-
- Yeah, it was just hilarious.
- How fucking absurd, how funny it is.
And also the, my poor mate,
who was like two windows over from me
who had to clean that shit off
because the school said
that it would take them
a week to get there.
- Right.
Take a week to get there?
- To come and out and clean it,
And he's like,
"I can't leave shit on
my window for a week."
(everyone laughs)
So funny, such a good story.
- And then this is another story too.
- Second character
development story, I guess.
- Normally when you want
to give your family,
like, good karma,
everyone in my family has been a monk,
like, twice in their life.
- What happened there?
Did I really?
- Yeah, check the suit, check the suit.
- We're good,(mumbles)-
- Oh, no, no, no.
(both gasp)
- Ashley, do you have a paper towel?
- Paper towel, paper towel.
Emergency situation-
- Add that to the monkey moment,
ladies, and gentlemen.
- Add that to the monkey moment.
I mean, this was,
I guess this is the first
time I've ever talked
about being a monk in public
despite how long I've
been on the internet.
And even like for the longest time,
even for like my closest friends,
nobody knew I was a monk
and I can't remember who-
- You told me this story-
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you have to like drag it out of me.
- Yeah, because I was like, what?
(Joey laughs)
What?
'Cause I don't know anyone around me
who used to be a monk.
That's fucking cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
I love how, at this rate,
my character development is me literally
coming out to my friend.
- That is your character.
- That's my character development.
- Joey was just like, I was a degenerate,
I still am a degenerative,
and I always will be.
- That I got very
homoerotic with my friend
while watching "Kisses".
And then what's the last clip there?
I can't see the last one.
- Oh, the most awkward elevator ride ever.
- Oh yeah, this is my story.
- This is a good one.
- Play the clip.
- This is a good one for the action alone.
- Door opens and this
like, black guy walks in,
he walks in really quietly, door closes,
starts going down,
and then he just goes, "oh yeah,
everybody's shuts up when
the N word walks in."
- I can only just fathom.
- You can't make that shit up.
- What I love about this story is like
how I can relate to that story
even though I wasn't there,
'cause like I can exactly
see that moment happening
like that could have
happened to any one of us.
- To this day,
that is still the scariest
experience I had in America.
Like hands down,
but for like a different reason.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
[Joey] Like honestly, what's gonna win?
- [Garnt] I have no
idea, I can't pick one-
- Because like it's a nice mixture, right?
Because it's a mixture of
like really hilarious moments
versus like really kind
of wholesome deep moments.
- I think that maybe
the monk one will win.
- Maybe.
- I feel like that's the most iconic.
- I don't know.
I'm thinking either the monk one
or the chess pro one.
- I mean in terms of like the stories,
people remember the monk
one and the chest one
I feel stand out because
that's like playing
a huge part in like our characters.
- True, true, true.
- But I feel like,
I feel like there were even more stories
in this that we didn't get
to put in on nomination-
- [Joey] Oh absolutely.
- Because there were like,
there's been so many good stories
that I've told and you guys
have told over the years
that I don't even remember
all of them right now.
So I can't pick one.
Honestly, this was fucking difficult.
- Garnt, tell us who.
- Oh yeah, it's me.
- You can't pick, so let's
just find out who did win.
- Well I'm glad I didn't have to pick
because the viewers picked.
And the best story of the year goes to
(drums play)
Connor becoming a chess pro.
Yeah.
- I mean look, it
inspired an entire special
so it makes a lot of sense.
This is deep in the "Trash
Taste" law, all right?
- It is, this one probably has one of the
most effects on like the trash tastes, law
and fucking character development.
' Cause I feel like-
- What is this fucking screen grab?
(Joey laughs)
- I even feel like this was
the first big story told on this podcast.
- I think so.
- Yeah, I can't-
- How much did it win by though?
- [Ashley] 30%.
- Oh very (mumbles)
- What's the second place?
- [Ashley] Second play was
Garnt's penis with, 26%.
- Don't say Garnts penis.
- What?
Garnts penis?
- How he drew a penis.
- Oh, okay.
- Not his actual penis.
- Hey guys, here the length of my ding.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Wow, okay.
- Fair enough.
- Fair enough, fair enough.
- What's the next category, Ashley?
- Let's go the next one.
Biggest clown.
- All right, I'm a head out.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, Garnt could win this one.
- I could win?
I thought I was going
to win this one for the-
- I think all three of us can make it-
- For my crust opinion alone,
but apparently that didn't win.
- I don't remember this.
- Let's take up the nominations though.
- All right.
- [Joey] So we got-
(Joey laughing)
Oh my God these photos!
- [Connor] I love how we chose the guests.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, we have,
So we have me, Connor,
Garnt, Sydney and Chris.
- I want Chris to win this one.
- I want Chris to win this one too.
- I would laugh if Chris-
- I hope Chris wins it '
cause Chris would be annoyed about it.
He would joke about
being annoyed about it,
but he would actually be annoyed about it.
- I can't get over Garnt's picture,
it's so funny.
- When was that taken?
That was at "AX" like, three years ago.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And I think that picture of Connor
is about six years old.
- Yeah, you look so young in that picture.
- I hate that photo so much.
- And this was last week.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, last week.
- I mean, (mumbles) find out who won.
- Yeah, I don't think we need
to go over the nominations.
- Yeah, this will be pretty
self-explanatory honestly.
- I've got to show this to the camera.
Got to get our money's worth.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Oh, look at that texture.
- Thank you, Ashley.
- Boys, who do you think
won the biggest clown?
- Honestly, any of these guys.
- I honestly like as much
as I want Chris to win,
I kind of think I want Garnt to win.
- Really?
- Just for the crust.
- For the crust?
- It depends, there's so
many different elements
that could play-
- I think you could also win it
just for being the monkey, right?
- Let's find out.
- All right, all right.
(drums playing)
- Fuck sake.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's Connor.
- Yay!
- The clown!
- How much did I win by?
It's gotta to be neck and neck.
- [Ashley] 58.
(everyone laughs)
- 58%?
58%?
- 58%!
- 50, what the fuck!
- Wait, who was second place?
- [Ashley] Second place was Chris with-
(everyone laughs)
- 58, what?
- 58 to 15.
- Chris came second.
- I was in a landslide what!
That's the biggest win we've had yet!
What!
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- This is a personal attack
and I won't forget this viewers.
- Oh my God.
- There's so many,
It's all flooding, right?
It's all flooding.
All the reasons are flooding into my head.
But of course he's the biggest clown.
- It's not like I just
got a drink or anything.
God damn it.
- My God.
- I hate it here.
All right, fair enough.
- What's the next nomination?
- What's the next one?
- [Garnt] Biggest Chad!
Bigger than Johnny sins.
- Oh my God.
- Oh God.
- All right, let's look at
the nominees for this one.
All right, we got.
Oh, I love the difference
in the pictures here.
- Chris Broad, has X to doubt on that one.
- Why does this look
like a mugshot of Chris?
So we got me Connor,
Garnt, Chris and Ladybeard.
Again, I love the fucking
difference in photos here.
- Yeah.
- We had the clown photos before
and now we've got the Chad-
- Great job, Ashley.
- You know in those pictures
of those Giga Chad pictures,
like the actual Giga Chad-
- Yeah, the chin one.
- When you found out like,
that's a real person not a CGI image.
That's how I felt when
I met like Ladybeard.
Because that blew my mind when I,
thought it was CG,
everyone thought it was CG,
And then it was real-
- What part of him is CG?
- No, no like the Giga Chad meme.
- Oh, the Giga Chad.
- The jawline.
- Yeah, because everyone though it was CG,
but it was a real dude
and he has brothers
and they all look and it's insanity.
And that's what it felt
like meeting Ladybeard.
- He is the Giga Chad after all.
- I mean-
- On paper Ladybeard wins.
- On paper I don't think anyone can argue
with Ladybeard being the biggest Chad.
- Like, this isn't about
being like subjective,
like objectively, he is the biggest Chad.
- Even if the voters say
otherwise it's Ladybeard.
- Yeah, it's gonna be Ladybeard.
- It's the first time I've
like been in the presence
of a Chad I'm like,
I know what it feels like to
have your empty sock towel
and just like taking
everything just to be in
the presence of this man.
I have a feeling I know who won this.
- All right, let's find out.
"Trash Taste" awardw biggest Chad
that goes to the Giga Chad of the year.
- Yeah.
Goes to,
Ladybeard.
- Oh!
- Well deserved, well deserved.
- Well deserved Ladyberd.
- I want to know who came last?
- Yeah, that's what I want to know.
So go in order, from first to last.
- [Ashley] First is, Ladybeard,
Connor, Ladybeard had 40.4%.
Connor in second place with 36%.
- Oh, your pretty close.
- [Ashley] And a third is, Chris with 13.
- What!
- Chris is more Chad than you two!
- What?
That's a fucking lie.
- Wait, 36, 32?
- [Ashley] Chris had 13.
- 13? Oh I thought he said 32.
- And then?
- [Ashley] Fourth place is Garnt.
- Oh, Joey's the lease Chad!
- Oh, I'm the lease Chad?
- [Ashley] You came in with 4.4%
- I love you, 4.4%!
(Connor and Garnt laugh)
- Ladybeard, well-deserved, well-deserved.
- Yeah, Ladybeard well-deserved-
- At least your not the
biggest clown, Joey.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's all good-
- I got biggest Chad, I got biggest clown.
I mean what's the point anymore?
- I thought there was going to
be like the dichotomy there,
but no, you couldn't beat the
Chad energy from Ladybeard.
- It's impossible-
- It's impossible.
- This is like the final boss you see,
I am buttered me arm hair
compared to Ladybeard.
- This is just a picture
and I'm still sitting here sweating, man.
Like Jesus.
- Things you don't want to see at night.
- Well-deserved.
- Well-deserved Ladybeard.
- This guy slapped your woman on the ass,
what'd you do?
- Nothing
- Thank you, thank you honestly.
All right, what's the next category?
- What's the next category?
- Best nickname.
- Oh, all right.
Let's look at the nominations.
Monkey brain Connor,
Steve Handjobs for Garnt,
Karen.
(everyone laughs)
Is that a nickname, really?
- It's gotta be now, I guess.
- I am going to quit this
podcast if that wins.
And then we have-
- Hey did you boys vote?
- Huh?
- Did you vote?
- I didn't vote.
- I'd vote Karen.
- I would vote Karen.
And then we have Garnt for God.
That's not a nickname,
that's his real name.
And then the 93% for Connor.
Honestly, at this point,
I want Karen to win.
- Do you like any of your nicknames?
- What do you think?
What do you think, Connor?
- This is the most current
picture he could have chosen.
- Where did we get this picture from?
- What is that picture from?
- This is when I did,
I think it was on like,
I did like a sushi video with Chris
on like a different channel
this was like four years ago.
And I'm wearing like the sushi hat.
Yeah, Jesus Christ.
- Steve Handjobs, do you
like that nickname, Garnt?
- I fucking love that nickname.
- I gave that to you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because I'm the
only one out of us three
of that parody wears turtlenecks.
- I can't pull off a turtleneck,
I look like a rapist.
- Steve Handjobs.
- Personally, I've been battling with
the Grant nickname for my entire life,
so I've really, really,
I really hope to God
that does not win.
- What do you think might win here?
- I have no idea to be honest.
- I feel like because I have two nicknames
that the vote could be split.
You know what I mean?
- Honestly, like, I feel
all of these kind of,
you know, scratch a different
itch for the viewer.
I mean I really don't know.
But let's find out, Connor.
- What's your favorite
nickname of the two?
- Steve Handjobs.
- Hell yeah.
- I hate Garnt.
Are you kidding me?
- What about you?
- If that wins we're gonna get a
new saltiest moment on "Trash Taste'.
- Wait, why you put
monkey with a "Y", Ashley?
What the fuck is that?
- Yeah, It's "M O N K E"
- Come on, that was pretty
monkey of you Ashley.
- I will say the one downside
having the 93% nickname,
is that whenever I fucking even interact
publicly with a girl everyone's
like it's a 93% of like,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
I'm just having a conversation.
Please stop.
Stop, you're making a weird, please.
- The things about 93%,
Is that, that was something that
that's the longest
lasting nickname, right?
'Cause that was mentioned in episode one.
And it's just stuck.
- I don't mind.
I just, sometimes I worry
about the other person
when there like talking to someone-
- Their like what does it mean?
- Connors trying to put the moves.
I'm like, "no, I'm
literally talking to woman,
please stop."
- Who knew you could have
a platonic relationship.
- And the "Trash Taste"
awardw for best nickname is-
- Not Karen, not Karen.
- Steve Handjobs!
- Yay!
- No way!
- I'm so happy about that.
- You know what?
I'll fucking take it,
I love that nickname.
- Oh, things I named never win.
- Can we get the breakdown of the votes?
- Lets get a break down.
- [Ashley] Steve Handjobs, won with 32.3%.
- That's pretty comfortable.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Second place
was Connor monkey brain.
- Of course.
- [Ashley] With 25.2%.
And last place was the 93%, with 19.2.
- Vote got split.
- Yeah.
They all scratched
different inches, right?
- Yeah.
- I think when you have two
ones that contend really well,
I think the vote might be split
because I think Steve
Handjobs is better than Garnt.
- Yeah, I think so.
- Like it's easier to vote.
- I think so.
No bias there, I think it's better.
- It's definitely better.
I'm so fucking glad Garnt
came like last, right?
Did they come last?
- [Ashley] Garnt? No, Garnt was fourth.
- Karen came last.
- Are you happy Joey?
- I love you guys.
- Gamers, gamers, PC gamers.
We have an extra special stream
coming up next week Connor,
give us the details.
- I'm glad you asked Garnt.
On the 2nd of June in Japan
or the 1st of June, if you're in America,
we will be doing a PC
building competitions stream.
Where we will take it
in turns to build the
ultimate gaming PC from "Gigabyte".
Who's been kind enough
to send us all the parts.
So we'll see who can build
the most monster PC in the timeframe-
Yeah
- That we have, which is unlimited.
Whoever does it, fastest wins
and whoever designed it nicely.
That means wires boys in the right places.
We'll also get bonus points.
- Yes, If you'd like to catch that live
and watch us make a clown of ourselves,
then make sure to go over
to twitch.tv/TRASHTASTE
links down on description below.
- And we'll be streaming at
these times on screen right now.
- No doubt it will be a very long stream.
'cause we're fucking everything up.
- See you then.
- Anyway, the next
category actually hit it.
What is it?
- Best complaining about America moments.
You mean the entire pod cast?
- Oh, well, well.
- When did this start to become a thing?
- I don't know.
I think I started casually
complaining about America
and we will joined in.
- What was the first
complaining about America?
- I can't remember what started
this and then it just like-
- There's so many to choose from.
- So many.
- I feel like this wasn't a thing
at the beginning of the podcast
and then something happened
and then like the flood gates just opened.
- Right?
- Like I can't remember.
- I think it's when our
audience kind of caught on
being like guys to complain
about America for some reason.
- I'm taking my jacket off for this one.
I'm getting hot over here.
- Its gonna get heated.
- Is a heated topic.
My favorite one.
- Let's look at the nominees though.
- Let's look at the nominations.
- Wearing your shoes on your bed.
- For fuck sake.
- I feel like we're going to be like this
for every single one.
- This is just gonna be
like a (mumbles) mention
of all our points.
- Like, "yeah, this is fucked up."
- Play the clip.
- They put like a cloth on the bed,
like a little, like, I don't know-
- Apparently it's so that you
can wear shoes on the bed.
- I still feel that way.
- I'm pretty sure that's what it is.
- Since I found that out, I
just, I hate that thing now.
- No, I didn't mind it.
I thought it was nice, but not legit.
- Ever since I found out about that,
the first thing I do when
it gets to one hotel,
rip that off, put it in the corner.
- Are you sure,
it just breaks the fucking
Geneva convention, right?
Like, how is this allowed.
- There is some really
important issues going on
in the world?
And this should be up
there, but number one,
this needs to be sorted out.
- The other one is American
pint versus British pint.
Play the question.
- It's just true.
American pint the biggest scam ever,
by the way you guys got
ripped off. I don't know why.
When Americans took the pint
from us, for some reason,
they made it smaller. This is true.
Yeah.
- Why would they do this?
And everything else bigger.
The only thing that matters.
The only thing that
matters, a pint. A pint.
How do you fuck that up?
- Literally
- How do you fuck that up America?
- the only thing where
you actually care about
your cost to quantity ratio is when
they're like, "whoa, hold on a second
Hold on. Let's make it smaller.
Let's not get too big with this."
(Joey laughs)
It's like, no, no.
- Especially when we were talking
about American beers as well.
You don't need less American
beers to get you drunk.
You need more of it.
- [Joey] More of it.
- What's this third one?
America is dangerous.
That's just a general statement.
Isn't it just a statement?
- Real nice.
I've never been to a motel.
So I don't fuck with those.
cause that's where people die in films.
- That's where fugitives
like hide out. Right?
- Every single thing that's
bad happens near a motel.
- Oh man. I don't even
remember that episode.
- I don't remember that episode.
- But I guess we'll talk about
how dangerous American motels are.
- I mean, it is. America is dangerous.
- I've never stayed at a motel before,
but I can just already tell.
- I mean, I really want to.
I want to simulate near death.
So I do want to say to my, that.
- I want to simulate my
favorite Quentin Tarantino movie
at a motel.
- Say somebody like changing
identities in the room next
to them and blowing up their car.
- I've actually stayed in a motel before.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah. I felt sketch as fuck.
- [Joey] Yeah right.
- Cause I remember like the first time
I take stayed in motel was like before AX.
And I remember getting to the
parking lot and I'm just like,
there's at least like been five people
who've been shot here.
(Joey laughs)
- I feel like, oh my God.
I feel like with someone doing
heroin around the corner or
something, it felt sketchy to be fair.
You can say that about
any street corner in LA.
- I'm sorry America.
- It was my first time in LA.
- I am sorry. I like
you America but come on.
- Yeah I love you too. But come on now.
American Food is Disgusting, this title.
- These titles are not
being generous are they?
- Taki took me to a Steak 'n Shake once,
which is where like the optimal
place of where you do that.
And I just saw like six Americans
dipping their fries into
the names of their shakes.
I'm just like, "I can't,
I can't be here."
Yeah, no. I couldn't.
It literally ruined my
Steak 'n Shake experience.
- My initial reaction there
is interesting because I am,
I don't really that against it. Right.
I, I don't, I don't hate it.
I've done it before.
I thought it was okay.
I understand the flavors and
why you'd want to do that.
- I love your fucking face there.
- Yeah. I know. I don't
know what my face is there.
(laughing)
- That's the kombucha meme.
- That's a pretty good screenshot.
- Put that on The Best Screen Grabs.
- The thing about American
food is that I don't actually
think American food is disgusting.
- It's either a one or
a 10. No in between.
Yeah. Exactly.
- It's a one or a 10.
- They either absolutely nail it
and they have the best
food on earth. Yeah.
Or they have like White Castle. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's either Five Guys, a White Castle.
It's top or the bottom.
- It's like, you, you either,
you either way you destroy your
body, but it's like, is it,
does it feel good or does it feel bad?
- Was it worth it?
- It's like the, you know, the,
what was the show that did
like the crazy/hot scale?
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- For like what's it
like, what's that show.
- I haven't got a clue
what you're talking about.
- I forgot the name of the show.
- I know what you're talking about.
- That I had an analogy there
then I completely lost it.
And then the last one is,
Americans Are a Different Species of Human
- Well it's true by the
clip. When was this clip?
- I love Americans,
but there's just like
just general life stuff
that's like what?
- Every time I go to America,
I'm like, this is another planet.
Like I can't relate to these.
(laughing)
- Well, thats
that's obviously a bit
of an over-exaggeration
I can relate to wonderful Americans,
this is some things where
I'm just like, alright,
I can't believe this is a thing.
- I couldn't remember all we
complained about that one.
- I can't relate to them at all.
I feel like America is
a very, just, you know,
out there in a good way. Most of the time.
I really appreciate
how open Americans are.
Sometimes you just wish they weren't.
But I mean, that's what anyone, yeah.
Actually people wish that
I would shut the fuck up
for 10 minutes sometimes so I understand.
- Yeah.
- Man. I mean, I,
I feel like the reason
we love complaining about
Americans is because we hang
out with a lot of Americans.
- Yeah right.
- I mean two of us are dating Americans.
- This is the thing as
well why people are like,
"Man, you know nothing
about American culture."
I'm like, "Man, you
really don't realize how,
how outside America works, do you?
It's literally all we get
is your fucking leftovers.
That's like leftover
movies, your leftover tv.
Unfortunately I do know how it works."
- It's until you see yourself
in the third person that you
realize, "wow, we're weird".
- Like out of all these,
hearing all of them again,
I'm just like wearing shoes on bed.
- Yeah. I'd say wearing shoes on bed.
- Because like,
I think like most of these,
I just like, you know,
some of them are annoying,
some of them are offensive,
whatever, to me,
I think this one offended
my entire generation.
Like my, like my fucking my ancestors
are like turning in that grave right now
hearing this opinion.
- Every Asian is pulling
their hairs out right now.
- I mean, it's true. Yeah.
- Yeah honestly.
- Your opinion.
We, we, we kind of grouped.
I remember,
I remember like we grouped like
the entire Western world and
like the Europeans are like,
"no this ain't our mess".
You know?
- No in the UK, some
households in the UK do that.
And that's how you know that
they are the weird kids,
you know?
- Yeah.
- I am curious because I feel
like most of the people voting
on this, are going to be American.
- Yeah. Right.
(laughter)
- I'm going to enjoy to
see what the Americans
from the south chose
as the best Americans.
- Let's find out.
- All right.
- As the one who
apparently complains about
America the most, I'm very honored
- Go on.
- to read out this award.
- Go on. Go on Conner.
- Oh this might surprise you.
- [Joey] What?
- Well, which one do you think it is?
It's I'll give you a clue, it's not,
it's not the one.
- Really?
- It's not the first one,
which one you think it is?
- Americans Are a
Different Species of Human.
- Hit the nail on the head Garnt.
(cheering)
A Different Species of Human.
- Wow. I wasn't-
- What percentage? Can
we get the breakdown?
Joey, go ahead.
- I was not expecting that.
- [Ashley] 41.9% of them.
- 41.9% of the votes?
- What's the second one?
- [Ashley] Wearing Shoes on Your Bed
- Good.
- [Ashley] With 25.3.
- That should've won.
- Yeah that should've
won. That should've won.
Well the thing is, we think
that shit is absolutely vile.
- To every American voting on it,
they're like, "well that's normal".
- A lot of them, they
just don't think of it
as a big deal. Yeah.
- I mean, fair enough.
Fair enough.
- Hopefully we have opened
your eyes just a little bit.
- Honestly that's just more OP for them.
For them. They can never
take their shoes off.
- I guess,
but everyone around them
is going to be grossed out.
- So I'm pretty sure
like humanity, regresses,
every time someone doesn't
take their shoes off
when they get on the bed.
- I remember.
I hate to call Rustage out like this, but
Rustage is when he came
to my house in Japan-
- Did that?
- He, you know, cause in Japan
you have the, what is it?
- Genkan.
- Genkan, I was like,
yeah, this is my house.
And I'm showing him,
cause the bathroom's right
next to the front door.
And he's like, "oh, cool",
starts walking in with the
shoes on, dirty into my-
I'm like, "Rustage! What have you done?"
(laughing)
- I am ashamed of you, Daniel.
You're better than that.
- I'm like scrubbing the floor.
- Come on, come on.
You're not even American, Rustage.
- I was like, "You're
not American Rustage.
What's your excuse?"
Sorry to call you out like that.
- It's not too late to change for us.
- It's not too late to seek help.
- You can change your ways.
- You can change.
- Sorry, I know you say I forgive you.
- Yeah. Now you know it for next time.
- All right. Next next category.
- Next category.
- Best Meme.
- This is gonna be a contested category.
- This is so fucking hard.
- The subreddit was just
fucking came out like
all right, let me see what we got.
- There is countless.
- I had so many.
- I don't even think
five or six nominations
or whatever can do this job.
- I'm pretty sure like going
through this is like when
humanity first discovered oil, you know,
it's just a goldmine. You can't lose.
- But what do we do with
this? There is so much of it.
(laughing)
- All right. Let's find out
what the nominations are.
Four.
- Oh, there's only four.
Okay. So we got
- [Ashley] Page one of three.
- Oh wow.
- This is page one of three.
(laughing)
- That's what I like to hear.
- Very nice.
- So the first one is Bottom Gear Mates.
- Which will have the full,
have the full screen version
on the site I presume.
- Yeah.
- We've got the Quote Collage.
- I love this one.
- This one goes on everywhere.
- It goes everywhere.
- I don't know why.
- It's like these two,
the Watching The Drift one.
I remember the Watching
The Drift one was just like
we got on r/all for this meme I think.
- Yeah yeah
- And that's how, you know
it was a good meme, right?
- It's made it on every subreddit.
- Because this was the only meme that-
- It was on Lwiay as
well. On Pewdiepie Lwiay.
- Lwiay?
- Oh really?
- Oh yeah that's right.
I think this is the only
meme out of all of these,
that didn't, wasn't actually
upvoted on our own subreddit,
but just got spread around
every other subreddit.
- I love this one though.
The Before and After the Hentai Episode.
(laughing)
- This is just the culmination of the
best screencaps.
- Yeah right?
- It's just meme made in Heaven.
- Yeah.
- All right. Let's look at the next page.
Don't Quote Us.
- Quotes.
- Ladybeard Man hug.
I like that name. I like that meme.
Connor Reacts.
I love this Connor reaction image.
- Do this on purpose. Do
you remember doing this?
- No I don't remember.
- I don't even remember the context.
- I don't remember.
- Like what did Reina say
that made you do that?
- I know she was saying something weird
And I was like, yeah, I don't know.
- And then we got, I love this one.
Garnt's Middle Finger.
- The middle finger one.
- Yeah. That one is so good.
- Oh this is the one
I mentioned earlier. I forgot
it was in this category.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah.
- That was like a good out of context.
A screenshot, almost a good meme.
( Connor mumbles)
And the last page you got
Strange Things to Ask.
I'm surprised, I'm
surprised this clip didn't
come to come out on like The
Best Out of Context Clip.
- [Joey] Yeah right.
- Put your finger- Have
you ever fingered yourself?
And I remember being like,
what? And you were like-
- Oh, me neither.
(laughing)
- Have you ever fingered
yourself? Uh what? Me neither.
Weird question.
I fucking love this, meme.
This is such a multi-layered meme.
That's so multi-layered, that's like you
have to be integrated
into the Trash Taste Law,
to get this meme.
- You need to understand the law here.
And the American Trash
Taste is a fantastic edit.
- [Garnt] This is a fantastic meme.
It's such a good idea.
And then this is a very recent
meme, which is hilarious.
- It's not really a Trash Taste meme.
- It's more of a my channel
meme, but I mean it works.
- It's just a Kaho meme actually.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe I guess maybe just how, how,
like wide the Trash Taste law goes
that this counts as like
a Trash Tastes meme.
Even though it's something like,
something I would say is like
in the extended Trash Tastes
cinematic universe, I would say
that that's that goes there.
- Do you have a favorite meme?
- Oh man.
- I don't know if I have a favorite meme
because all of these memes
are fucking fantastic.
- Can we go back to the first one?
- I would probably have to say
the Watching the Drift meme,
just because there were
so many iterations of
it and it made its rounds so far.
- I do like the Bottom Gear one.
- Bottom Gear one.
- Bottom Gear one,
I fucking love that one.
- It's just a good pic
of like three mates.
- Yeah.
- Honestly that pic could
go my wall when I'm like 80.
And I was like-
- I remember that!
- Just me and the boys
living our best life.
I love that one. That was
great. I just like that one.
- I think, oh, I dunno.
This is, this is difficult.
- This is difficult. This is really hard.
- I also love the fucking-
I mean, this is just best screenshots.
I love the American Trash Tastes meme
because I feel like that
just like epitomizes
Trash Tastes and like-
- This single handedly,
motivated me to not get fat.
(Garnt laughs)
- I was like, if I'm
going to look like this,
I am fucking not going
to get to this point.
- Health and health defects,
and all their problems,
looking fat, na-
This coming after the
Complaining About America
Moment Category.
- It's beautiful. Right.
Can't make this up.
- It's such a beautiful, right?
It's such a beautiful-
- I'm interested to see the order of-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah that's
what I'm wondering too.
- But let's find out
who the winner is there.
- All right.
What do you guys think?
You got to say one. You got to say one.
- I don't know, I don't know.
Honestly. I think I'm Gear Mates.
I think it could be quotes of us three.
- Quotes?
- Us three, our quotes -
- All right. Let's find out.
- 'cause that's everywhere.
Trash Tastes Awardw with "best meme"
goes to the Quote Collage.
(Cheering)
- I was right.
- I mean, this did make the rounds.
- Should we all read the
quotes? I'll read mine.
"If everyone is rich, then
nobody is broke. Right?"
- [Joey] I don't remember you saying that.
- I remember saying this one.
And I was immediately one
of those things. I was like,
I hope no one noticed how
stupid that thing I said was I
meant to say something else,
but I just said that I totally
did not mean to say that,
but it came out and I was like,
no, one's going to notice this..
People noticed.
- And then my one is a "Young
people are young, dumb,
and full of cum."
That's not even that shouldn't
even be attributed to me.
'Cause my dad used to say that.
And then yours is-
- "If you set your mind to it,
you can jack off to anything."
- Was this from Trash Taste?
- I don't think it was.
- I think this was from my own channel.
I don't even remember which video it was.
- But what were the percentages? Ashley?
- Yeah. What was the percentage?
- [Ashley] Uh the winner was
Was the winner with 19.9%.
- Oh my god.
- 19.9%.
- Oh, that was actually quiet.
- Yeah.
- Actually if there's 12, at
19%, is considered percentage.
- Well, what was second place?
- [Ashley] Second place was a
Conner as the fucking T-Rex.
- Oh!
- Oh! Really?
- I would have loved it.
- T-Rex came second.
- What percentage? What percentage?
- [Ashley] 11.4
- Ah 11.4. I would have loved to have won.
I would've focused on one more.
- So that's a really,
that was a great meme.
- That was a great meme.
- That is such a mult-
that's like, that is
such a Trash Taste meme.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Go through them all.
- Yeah, go through the all.
Third place?
- [Ashley] Third place,
in, with 10.9% is Kaho.
- Oh.
- Really? Kaho?
Recency bias. Yeah.
- [Ashley] Fourth with
9.7% of the vote was,
it was A Strange Question to Ask.
- Oh. A Strange Question
to Ask. I do love that.
- The thing we missed.
- That was like a perfect combination
of two different memes.
(laughter)
- That's when Trash Tastes
and any memes can connect.
(laughter)
- [Ashley] Fifth with 9.5%. is the
Before and After Hentai Episode.
- Oh yeah, that was good.
I love that one.
Honestly. They're all good.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Sixth with 7.5%
was Bottom Gear Mates.
- Bottom Gear mates. Oh I wish that was a
little bit higher personally.
- I do wish that was a
little bit higher. Yeah.
- [Ashley] 10.2%. One is
Garnt's Middle Finger.
- Oh, the screenshot.
- Oh.
- Whoa.
- Oh which one came last?
- [Ashley] Yeah, the one
that came last was number six
which is, Ladybeard's Man Hug.
- Oh yeah. Okay.
Okay.
- I mean out of a Ladybeard episode,
I think the one where he
like leans into my mic was a
better one personally, but yeah.
Well-deserved I guess.
- What is up?
- Those were so many good memes.
Sub Reddit doing its work.
I hope you guys continue to do your work.
- All right. What's the next one?
- Let's look at next category.
What is the next category?
- Best tangents.
This whole podcast is a
tangent, damn straight.
- I dunno how we like narrowed
this one down because I feel,
I feel like the entire podcast is just-
- Every moment on every episode
- I think this one is based on
the severity of the tangent.
- Yeah.
- How far it went like that.
- Yeah, how far. We just
did a 90 degree turn
and yeah, there's a lot.
There's an awful lot.
- Let's look at the categories though.
All right, Ladybeard's Show Curtain.
This one is by far, my favorite.
- I could see this one
winning based off how strongly
people will remember this one.
Yeah, because it was so recent.
I remember this one. And
from when it came up,
when it came up, we all were like,
what the fuck is this tangent?
So I could just on that.
I could see this winning.
- Okay. Play the Clip.
- I have, I have, sewn my shower curtain.
(laughter)
- What is going on?
What is actually going on?
(laughing)
- I love the like just
half a second pause of
just our brain's processing
what he just said.
- It just came out of nowhere.
Absolutely out of nowhere.
- I don't think I've ever
felt physical whiplash from a
conversation until like I was
on a podcast with Ladybeard.
- This is true. This is true.
- Like, you know,
you like compared to the drifting
episode where we were like
feeling the Gs turning the corner.
Now the Ladybeard episode
was like, I felt more gs,
having a conversation with
Ladybeard than I did ever did
during the drifting episode now.
- And then the second one is
Talking About Poop. I mean,
- this could be, could be any
of them, we'll play the clip.
- Why do we talk about shit
as like, every time we start?
- No we don't. Don't fucking use this.
- Use this.
(laughter)
- Is that a tangent?
More like a Best Intro.
- Intro tangent, because we
couldn't even do an intro.
- Actually tangented
right at the beginning.
- I think it's supposed to symbolize
as going off about poop in general.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Isn't that like the
clip, but it's kind of
like symbolize about it.
- I mean, it's just like a theme.
Whenever we talk about
poop. It is a big tangent.
- Yeah. Chris Hijacks a Yacht.
I remember this.
- I remember this one.
- I got really drunk and
nearly hijacked a boat
with my Estonian friend in London.
- Wait what?
You can't just say that.
- I can't go into detail.
- Why come on?
(laughter)
- I love, I couldn't
even like talk about it.
He's just like,
I'm gonna just drop this
bombshell and see you later.
- Can't make this shit up.
- I remember there was like a
few stories that Chris told on
that podcast. We were
just like out of nowhere,
like how he's like surfed with
Elon Musk or something like.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And like a castle, right?
- Yeah.
- I remember the exact moment.
'Cause I, cause like I dropped,
I was opening a bottle of wine
and I dropped the wine bottle
bottle opener with such discuss that
he hadn't told me about this before.
- Why Chris?
- And then I'm talking about Saber.
Phase zero, watch, watch
unlimited blade works.
And then that's, that's
like the mainline timeline.
So you can enjoy Heaven's fuel.
And then if you want to enjoy
more of the fate franchise,
you can, because none of
it's technically Canada.
- This as the only
episode where I was like,
"when are they going to stop?"
- But I legit was like I
zoned out and I was like,
I'm going to come back into this.
- And I remember this episode
because it was, it was most,
it turned it to mostly a fate episodes,
even though we didn't plan it at all.
And that started completely
just from a tangent.
And then that's turned into
like a 17 to 20 minute tangent.
That's a kind of like
rotted your mind. I think.
- I think I was actually,
I'd never wanted like to stop
recording and be like, can we,
can we change the topic?
We've never done that before. I've never,
we've never asked to like move on. Yeah.
That was the one time in
like, I'm going to do it.
I'm going to ask.
- I'm gonna say it.
- Luckily he stopped.
- Stop.
- Talk About America, play the clip.
The way I talk about Americans
is like the way I liked,
like to shit on my cousins.
You know what I mean?
It's it's, it's like
the distant cousin that
I just like to talk shit about.
- We don't hate on America.
We just like making fun of America.
- I love that that
sentence alone could have
been so out of context.
I love talking about Americans.
like I like shitting on my cousin.
Just stop the sentence there.
- Then you have this one.
- Yeah I got this one.
I mean for this one, post biased
Ladybeard Shower Curtain.
I think that was the tangent
that sticks out to me the most.
- Oh, that's hundred percent.
- I think Trash Taste is
like, I mean, we talk,
we tangent about poop and
tangent about America all the
time.
- They're just not like strong
enough in the memory of an
iconic moment.
- In terms of the biggest whiplash.
Ladybeard, number one,
I say Chris Hijacks a Yacht, number two.
- Cause like the shower curtain
moment was like a buildup of
about 15 more tangents that
we were like building on to
that. And it seemed
like the dumbest of all.
Yeah. I've never heard a
sentence that started with,
So my shower curtain- until this episode.
- You really pushed the limit. So yeah.
- All right.
- Garnt, who won? Let us find out.
So the best tangent goes to
the Ladybeard Shower Curtain.
(Clapping)
- [Joey] Unsurprising.
- Well deserved.
Well deserved.
- I wonder how much of a
landslide this one was.
- This one, what was the
percentage for this one?
- This, this should have
been one of the biggest ones.
- Yeah probably.
- [Ashley] 29.4
- Oh, not that much.
- Not that much.
- 29.4
- [Ashley] Second place
was Chris Hijacking a Yacht
with 22 points.
- Chris Hijacking a Yacht.
- Yeah, yeah yeah, as I said, one and two.
Yeah, those are definitely
the biggest ones.
Oh good. Well done Ladybeard.
- Well done Ladybeard.
- That's two awards you've won so far.
- Biggest tangent and
biggest Chad goes to you.
- What is the next category?
- Let's find out.
Best Trash Taste Special Moment. Oh, okay.
So I mean, this is going to
be pretty narrow down I guess,
because there's only been three specials.
- Originally we had Best
Trash Tastes Special and
then we kind of realized
there's only three specials.
There's not really much to choose from.
So let's narrow it down to the
best moments you enjoyed from
the Trash Taste specials.
- All right, let's look at the nominees.
So what are the nominees?
Conner Breaks 2 Cars.
Of course. Play the clip.
(tires screeching)
(whimsical chiming music)
- 'Cause eventually though, I
might've done a small oopsy.
- Your fucking face is priceless.
- I heard the fucking clutch-
- I heard it from all the way up the top.
We were like, whoa,
what the fuck is that?
- I just fucking died
and was like, oh fuck.
- My favorite shot of this
is when you were just like,
"I bet Garntz, giggling away at his car"
and I'm just fucking
losing it in my own car.
- I know you too well, okay?
- I remember seeing you
break it. And I just, I just,
I just couldn't contain
myself. I thought it was,
I thought it was like the most
on-brand kind of thing that
could ever happen.
- What can I say?
- Monkey brain breaking two cars.
- And then I was like, all right,
we got the dub and then Conner like,
"finna break another one."
(laughs)
Yeah, honestly.
And then next one is Garnt
Wins the Chess Tournament arc.
- Oh man, this was, I can't rewatch this.
- This was the biggest upset, wasn't it?
Play the clip,
- Play the clip.
(Laughing)
- Fuck you Conner! Fuck you!
Oh my God. You were the
protagonist the whole time?
You were the protagonist the whole time?
Oh my God.
- Look at her. Look at her.
- I threw her. I threw her.
- Look at your face man.
- You were like nutting
there and what an, what?
An amazing moment.
- What amazing w that was.
Probably like top five best moments of my
life.
- I never threw so hard
in my life, you know?
I just played shit.
I was like, this,
- This wasn't so much funny
as much as it was just like,
you couldn't script this, right?
If like I'm,
I'm surprised how well the
Trash Tastes Toilet Arc was just
like came out, like, like
it was like an anime script.
- Yeah. Honestly, you know,
- Like all three of us
got top three even though-
- The most proud third place
I've ever taken in my life.
- And like biggest plot
twist of the entire arc,
which is me coming out on top.
- It's the protagonist powers, man.
That's another piece of the law, right?
- Protagonist Powers.
We have the protagonist arc.
We have the antagonist arc.
- I don't want to talk about it.
- How do you feel about this Conner?
- Not good, not good.
- All right this next one
is probably my favorite.
Garnts Cycling Meltdown.
Play the clip.
(Classical music)
- You know what, fuck
listing off things I like.
How about listing things off I hate?
Joey, for being an Australian dickhead.
Who's fucking ahead of me right now.
- I love the classical
music in the background.
It's so fucking perfect.
- It's very fitting.
- I'm just like this moment would have
wouldn't have worked so well if you didn't
film yourself eating the ice cream,
- Honestly, a hundred
percent coincidental.
I didn't even know it was recording.
- We never turned the cameras off,
that's what I keep telling people.
- We never turn the cameras off, exactly.
- Honestly, I think what this, like,
this was the most British
moment of my life.
I don't think like, I don't think I,
because I don't think I've
complained about things more in
my life than like this exact moment,
because definitely I was
just dying by this point.
I just, I just needed to let
out some complaints, man.
- Sorry Garnt.
- It got you through, man.
- Got me through. You got me through.
- And then the next one is almost dying
in the backseat of a drift car.
To this day this is still,
this was still terrifying.
(upbeat music)
- [Garnt] I love you guys.
(screeching tires)
- The Gs felt insane. Insanity.
- I still remember his
like maniacal laughs.
- I wish that we got picked
up more on. We all were there.
I kept fucking laughing.
Like he'd be like drifting
around the corner,
pumping this handbrake,
and looking at it us
like-
I've never seen anybody move a handbrake
like this in my life.
- Like the adrenaline rush after.
- It's very intense.
- It's not anything that I
could ever describe. Right?
Because the adrenaline rush for that
was by far the biggest adrenaline rush
I had felt in my entire
life. Hundred percent.
- I can see how people get addicted
to adrenaline after doing that.
- Oh yeah, I wish I could drive that good.
- Yeah. Right.
- Instead, I break the cars.
- I was like, "is this
handbrake even working?"
You're like moving it around so much.
Like I don't even know
we're not doing anything.
- And the final moment,
the boys cheated, cycling.
- My favorite.
- Those boys, not me by the way.
- Play the clip.
- Garnt, over?
Hey Conner.
Bye!
Bye.
- Oh.
- You're fucking "Oh," is so funny.
- I'm so sad to this day
to this day about it.
- All right. Let's find
out the winner though.
Honestly. Fuck man.
Any of these could win.
These are great moments.
Just were all great moments.
- Just reliving these moments is just, we-
I like, what I love about
the specials is that
I have a fucking great
time filming the specials.
Ya know?
- And it's a fantastic trip
down memory lane, right?
This doesn't feel like six months ago.
- I thought the drifting
one was difficult to film.
And I was like, oh, that
stuff's hard to film.
And then we'll get the cycling.
I'm like, oh no, this is hard to film.
- Oh yeah.
- This is very difficult.
- I'm I'm surprised how well
the cycling moment came out,
which like fucking mvp of
the cycling special, Mudan,
going through a hundred hours of footage.
- Like I got a hundred hours of footage.
Like slots like six,
eight cameras, six GoPros,
which we're constantly filming.
We dead ass went, "Hey Mudan, here's
a hundred hours of
footage, turn it into one."
- It was like half a
terabyte of video files.
It was a lot, a lot in
this audio and stuff.
It was Snapchat. Yeah.
- Mudan's a beast.
- MVP Mudan.
- Yeah. But that can only be one winner,
unfortunately gentleman.
Who do you want to win again?
- Ahh, fuck me.
These are all so good.
I personally want Garnt Cycling
Meltdown to win I think,
cause that just was
hilarious. I don't know yet.
The editing was hilarious.
Garnt going off was hilarious.
- I think, you know, objectively,
I enjoyed the chess
winning by me the most.
- Fuck off. That better not win.
If that wins, I'm not reading it out.
- That's just me.
I think my cycling meltdown is
weird because during filming,
I hated it, but like it was, it was,
it was just like the moment
where I look at it and I'm just
like, okay, I'm glad my
suffering made for good content.
- Exactly, exactly. But let's
find out who's suffering
made for the best content in this award.
Oh it's upside down.
It's like this. Okay.
(Drum rolls)
It's Garnt's cycling meltdown.
- Aye!
(clapping)
Well deserved! Well deserved!
- The worst screenshot right there.
- Did you think it was me then
for a second or the chess?
- Yeah I did.
- My heart skipped for a second.
- I wanted to do a little
bait and switch there.
- Good on it.
- Congratulations Garnt.
Your meltdown is the most iconic moment of
the Trash Taste specials.
What is the percentage of
the votes that Garnt got?
- [Ashley] Garnt won with a 28.5%.
- 28.5%. Oh it's pretty close.
Relatively close.
Relative.
- Second place was Garnt
winning the chess tournament
with 24.6%.
- Wow that was close.
- Glad I didn't win, fuck
Garnt, its what I'm missing.
- Jesus Christ.
- I mean okay, yeah.
- It's okay Conner.
One, one day.
You'll have your time to shine.
Hopefully next-
- Well deserved Garnt.
Congratulations on your win yet again.
- Please look.
- Maybe. One day you'll win
your own Trash Taste Special.
- Please look forward to
more Trash Taste Specials
because they are on their way.
- I'll win the next one.
- And we'll get some
more fantastic moments
from the specials.
- What is the next category, Ashley?
Best Drip, even Goku doesn't look as good.
I doubt that.
(laughing)
- No one looks as good as Drip Goku. Yeah.
- What are the nominees?
- [Garnt] What the fuck is this?
- [Joey] So we got Garnt's
Steve Handjobs turtleneck.
- [Connor] Of course, of course.
- [Joey] We got Ladybeard's outfit.
We got my tophat.
That's not even drip. That's
just like a piece of clothing.
- [Connor] It's drip. It's drip.
- [Joey] My Berserk shirt
which is very recent.
I don't even remember that episode.
- [Connor] I think that was because
we mentioned it on the live stream.
- [Joey] Yeah on the live stream.
And then Connor's t-shirt
that you see him wear
like five times in a row.
- The Emiya shirt, yeah.
One of the memes that
didn't get shown here,
which is kind of unlike Shirou Emiya
but he wouldn't get it because he
doesn't watch Fate anyway.
- I've seen Fate/Stay
- Night.
Unlimited Blade Works.
- Just name them all, just name them all.
- Something, Grand Order.
- Yeah, there you go. Nailed it.
If there's anything I don't want to win.
It's my top hat because that's not drip.
That's literally just a hat.
- I really just want
the turtleneck to win.
- I want the turtleneck to win.
I love how it's Steve Handjob's
turtleneck, not Garnts.
- It's not my turtleneck.
- No, it's Steve Handjob's.
- It's the Steve Handjob turtleneck.
- You would think if Steven
Handjobs was in the nickname
category, there might be a bit of,
a bit of a leaning towards this.
- I have a feeling.
- Yeah.
- So let's find out who won this category.
- Best Drip goes to, Steve Handjobs.
(clapping)
Look how happy my boy is!
- He knows he's going to go
and buy as many turtlenecks-
- You got to do the go-to flex. Oh yeah.
What was the percentage Ashley?
- [Ashley] Garnt won with 49.9 percent.
- Whoa.
- 50%. Oh my God.
- I'm sad I'm not gonna be able to
wear turtlenecks till
winter rolls around again.
It's fucking boiling right now.
- In second place?
- [Ashley] Second place
was Ladybeard with 23.2 %.
- That is a Gigguk Chad dream.
- Who came last? Was it Jerry's top hat?
- [Ashley] No it was Joey's Berserk shirt.
- Oh okay.
- I mean, yeah, because that's
just, that's just, a shirt.
- That's just normal.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Grasping at straws for
that fifth nomination.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Jesus Christ.
- All right. What's the
next category Ashley?
- [Ashley] Laziest Drip.
- Oo.
- Fuck.
- You'd swear this person only has the
one outfit in their wardrobe.
- So the laziest drip to explain-
'cause it probably doesn't
make a whole lot of sense,
person I think who wore the
same amount of shirts for the
longest time, right?
- Yeah.
- Something like that
but let's, let's, let',
let's see you. Let's see you.
I remember.
- Oh Wow.
We old.
Okay so there is me and Connor, and Garnt.
- But didn't Chris get
nominated in this originally?
- He did?
- I swear he did, and like-
I remember when we got like
the original nominations
from like the survey, Chris
was on there for some reason.
And we had to remove him.
- Did he wear the same shirt twice?
- I don't know.
- No, he didn't.
- I was going to say-
- I'm excited.
I don't know where my Trash
Taste t-shirt is. I've lost it.
- Really? Lost it?
- I don't know where it is.
- I mean, I personally haven worn
I personally have worn this
Junji Ito shirt on the podcast.
- I've worn that Nerf shirt many times.
- I thought it was okay to wear
the Trash Taste t-shirt multiple times.
- Yeah. The fucking
real winner of this is?
The fucking Jojo shirt
that we got from Glamb.
- Glamb.
- They already got some
good promotion out of us.
- They do, they do.
The amount of times like collectively
between the three of us
we've worn the Glamb Jojo shirts,
every episode secretly sponsored by Glamb.
- We aren't sponsored by Glamb by the way.
We just loved their show. Exactly.
- [Ashley] FYI, Chris was on the poll.
- Chris was on the poll.
- Oh, okay. Wait, wait
for the, for the votes?
- [Ashley] Yeah, for Laziest Drip.
- Why was he removed?
- 'Cause he's only been in two episodes.
- How many votes did he get?
- [Ashley] Well, you'll find out.
- Okay, we'll find out.
So Chris was on the original poll.
I mean, there's not much to say.
- Who do you think is going to win it?
I feel like it might be me.
- It's you feel like it it is you, yeah.
- I feel like it's me.
- I feel it is is you.
- I think it's me.
- Yeah.
- Garnt is always insulted by my t-shirts.
- I think I've seen your
Emiya shirt about 10 times.
- I like that shirt.
- It's a nice shirt.
- I mean, it it's, it's like, I, I,
I can remember when you wear
something different because if
it's not the Emiya shirt,
or one of like your drab
kind of like t-shirt colors-
- Drab? How dare you!
Brown is a great color for a t-shirt.
- So one of the, one of the,
in one of the Netflix specials,
Joey only bought like one outfit or you
didn't bring enough outfits
or something like that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so he had to borrow Conner's shirt
and of course it was just
like a dark red gray.
- You can immediately tell, it was like
the color of drywall.
(laughing)
- Joey walks in.
- I'm just like Joey, this
looks like the least Joey
outfit I've ever seen you wear.
- I would never wear this personally.
- I need something to tone down
my white, white, white skin.
- Just wear black.
- I do. But I like-
- I like how all the screenshots
are us wearing black.
- We're all wearing black, yeah.
There was a guy on Reddit who
actually did the calculations
and went through every single episode.
- He actually quantifiably
figured out who had
the laziest drip.
- Oh okay.
- The Trash Taste one, Runway.
- This took way too long,
it's not even funny.
Looks like a 3rd grade project.
( Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Actually counted every single shirt
that reappeared and was worn twice now.
- So do we have the results of this?
- [Ashley] I have the results
of this on the next page.
- Oh okay, so let's look
at the results then.
- So scientifically speaking,
Conner had 29 unique outfits.
And so you wore the Trash
Taste shirt four times.
So you're repping in the show the most.
- I wore it two episodes
back-to-back as well.
- Okay.
- I think that was the two
episodes we promoted it.
- Probably.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think we all wore
it that episode, but-
- [Ashley] This is the
only page I have of the
Trash Runway.
- Oh this is the only page?
- Why?
- [Ashley] I just didn't include it.
- Okay. I mean, it doesn't matter.
Yeah. It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter. Conner came last.
- Yeah. If you want to look
at that, if you want to look
at the full thing of this, then
we'll leave the link to this
in the description, I guess.
But yeah, a shout out
to Nopir389 on Reddit.
- You did it!
You did God's work.
- Who was the winner
Garnt, of the Laziest Drip?
- The winner is-
- Voted by the viewers.
(drum roll)
(laughing)
- All right, I have a
feeling it's not Conner.
- No!
- It's Chris Broad!
(laughing and clapping)
- Yeah!
- You did it Chris!
- You did it Chris, you've won an award!
- You won an award for the Laziest Drip.
Even though you've been on the show twice.
- What was the percentage?
- [Ashley] He won with 50.8.
(laughing)
- 50.8%.
- 50?
- 50%!
- By a landslide!
- I want to see the other shirt he wore,
other than this one, what
was the other shirt he wore?
- [Ashley] The navy blue collared.
- Oh my God. Which is in that video,
there's a navy blue shirt.
- Wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
So who came a second?
- [Ashley] Uh, Conner.
- Yeah Conner, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Ashley] Third was Joey with 9.7.
- Wow.
- This is hilarious. Best moment so far.
- Chris, Congratulations.
- Congratulations.
- You won an award.
- You won the Laziest Drip award.
Congratulations, Chris. Congratulations.
- Next time we meet up
we'll we'll give you
an a, physical award.
- I think we are good
mocking Chris, that's why
we put it in, we were
like, "Yeah put Chris in".
- I think this was meant to be like
a joke nomination, right?
- Right.
- Yeah, because the
results are already there.
Right? We already know
quantifiably who won.
- Well we know who is
scientifically proven
to have the Laziest Drip.
We know who is the
winner in everyone's hot.
- It doesn't matter the science,
it matters with a feeling.
And we all feel that Chris
is the laziest guy we know.
(Joey laughs)
- So it's just like, you know, you know,
obviously everyone got the
same feeling, just emanates,
lazy drip energy,
- Exactly, exactly.
- Obviously.
- Come on, Chris, you gotta,
you gotta up your drip game Chris.
- You gotta step it up Chris.
- Yeah.
- But the next category is
one of my favorites actually.
[Conner] The Best Trash
Taste Animated award.
- [Joey And Garnt] Oo.
- [Conner] And God knows we've got way
too many to choose from.
- Yeah we've got a lot of
animators to choose from.
- There's a lot of really good
channels of them, honestly.
Like I don't think anybody
expected the animations
to be made, but we're so flattered and
honestly we are really really grateful.
- And so many of the
animations are so good.
- So good.
- They're fucking fantastic.
- Please keep them coming.
We always share them
on our channel as well.
But yeah let's look at the nomination.
So we've got The Great Burger Debate.
I think it's by Man in a Motel.
- Very good. Just tons of
clips. Go check out his channel.
- Some of the hardest parts were actually
picking which video to
put on this nomination.
- Oh are these videos?
- [Ashley] Yeah.
- Oh yeah, show the clip.
- Yeah show them off.
- The best part of a hamburger,
it's like the pizza thing, dude.
It's the synergy.
It's all the accumulation of
the tastes that come together
and they strike slightly, moderate.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Slightly moderate.
- Nice.
- It's so good. I love as
well how he makes all of us
like really look like how
we are. It's so perfect.
And then we have the Jujutsu
Kaisen Trash Taste collab.
- Can we play this audio?
- Yeah, I don't think we
can play this audio, can we?
- Can we share some of it.
We can play the audio out loud now
but in the video we have to-
- Yeah we have to sensor it unfortunately.
(hopeful rousing music)
- God, the amounts of references,
they were able to grab
in such a short time span
is like incredible in this one.
- Honestly, all of these,
honestly, are just
crammed with references.
Yeah. I mean, if we're
talking about references-
- Oh this one, this one.
- This is Conner Wakes Up.
- This one is pure references.
- This one is fucking amazing
- Let's play this one.
- I just imagined you in the
morning every, every morning,
like in the mirror going,
"You got this Conner, you got this."
(punching sound)
- C'mon.
- You fucking got this!
- Okay. So good.
- It's so good. So well animated.
Absolutely fantastic.
And then we got Mori Calliope,
Can't Say the F word.
This one made its rounds because
of the Hololive subreddit.
- Yeah, yeah of course, of course.
- But, uh play the clip.
- [Mori] Sorry I really
shouldn't curse anymore.
- [Joey] You can curse on
the show, it's alright.
- [Mori] I can? Is it okay?
- [Conner] Yeah. It's totally good.
- [Mori] You won't get mad?
- [Garnt] She's gonna say it!
(Garnt laughing)
- She's gonna say it!
(Conner laughing)
- [Mori] I can't do it on command.
- Oh, it's so good,
- Trash Taste On the Rocks,
one of the earliest ones.
This is good.
- Trash Taste of the Rocks.
This one is fantastic.
- [Conner] We got to
do a scene with Kermit.
I didn't even get to say anything.
He's fucking laser
beamed onto this Kermit.
- [Joey] Finally, something I can fist.
(maniacal laughing)
- I love that one.
- Honestly, I can't
even choose a favorite,
these are all so good.
- I mean, we could only have
five nominees for this one,
but honestly, every single
animated we've received
has been fucking fantastic.
So please, keep it up.
- We really love your work and we
love watching them as well.
Yeah, absolutely.
- But unfortunately, as
with every award show,
there can only be one winner.
- Viewers got to vote that choice.
We'll see which one is their favorite.
And I honestly, I have no idea-
- I don't know either.
- Any of these could win man.
- I have a feeling which one
might win, but we'll see.
- Okay.
- And the winner is-
- Oh, oh okay.
It's the Jujitsu Kaisen X Trash Taste.
- Oh okay, okay.
- Okay.
In terms of like animation,
this one is like, wow.
- It's pretty cool, it's pretty cool.
- The thing that was cool
about this one was that
it like the original
ending for Jujutsu Kaisen
was like original enough.
And they managed to get
the style down to a T.
- Yeah, insane.
- And that's what I think that's
what impressed me the most
out of this one.
Honestly, they all impressed me.
- Yeah. Honestly.
- Anyone like, I feel
like out of like, we,
it feels weird, tough to
award one of the winners.
'Cause I would just want
to give everyone a voice.
- You're all winners.
You're all winners.
- Everyone's a winner.
- Everyone's a winner. Everyone claps.
- But uh what were the percentages?
- [Ashley] Uh, 20. This
one was the one with-
- The two vote difference.
- Oh
Okay. So this was the one
with the two vote difference.
- Okay so out of what, 24,000 votes,
this only won by two votes.
- Oh my God.
- Wow.
So what was the, what
was the second place?
- [Ashley] Second place?
Second one was Mori Calliope.
- Oh!
- I thought that one was going to win.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That has a lot of views too.
- And Third, fourth, fifth?
- [Ashley] Third was A Great
Burger Debate with 22.9%.
- [Ashley] Fourth was How Conner Wakes Up.
- I love that one.
- Mhmm.
- [Ashley] And in Fifth place
was Trash Taste on the Rocks.
- Well they're all, they're
all bangers obviously.
- They're all fantastic.
- Fantastic stuff. Yeah.
- Honestly fantastic.
But if you guys want to submit animations,
then just make sure to title your videos,
Trash Tastes Animated, so
it's easy for us to find.
And then yeah, go ahead and
animate any moment of us.
- Yeah please @ us on Twitter.
- This actual winner, I think
it was three weeks after
it was uploaded before either
any one of us saw it. Right.
Because nobody saw it at all.
- Please @ us on Twitter
or at least title it
Trash Taste Animated, so
it's easy for us to find.
Yeah. But yeah.
Keep your animations
coming. We love all of them.
- And the next category is actually,
what is it, Best Rant?
- Best Rant.
- Oh God, there's so many!
- There's so many!
- This is, this is just like
90% of the podcast, right?
- This is like Best Tangent, right?
It's like there's (indistinct)
That could be like four or five
nominees from each episode.
- When aren't we ranting
about something? Jesus.
- There were some
standout rants I will say.
These are some of my favorites.
- Let's look at the nominees.
The Great Burger Debate.
I mean, we just saw the Man in the Motel
animation (indistinct).
Play the clip.
- Let's see it in 4k.
- Hamburger is not-
- Do you know what by itself means?
- A hamburger is not a patty by itself.
You got like potatoes, you
got vegetable, you got eggs.
- You can put some cheese
on that shit if you want.
- You got cheese.
- Oh my God. That's a good rant
when we just fucking
screaming from the get-go.
- I do not remember being that heated.
(Joey laughs)
- What? I, We couldn't shut you up.
- I remember you being heated.
'Cause I was laughing the entire time.
- This was obviously me running
on pure adrenaline and rage.
- I think so.
- Because I do not remember this.
I'm not looking at this and
I do not remember saying
the words that I did or being that.
- I've never seen you this angry.
- Yeah. It's every influencer apology,
"I don't remember the words that I said.
I do not apologize."
- Real Lapse of judgment?
- A severe lapse of judgment.
- Honestly, I- I- I
would give, I would like,
If if I sound like this,
I'd give an apology video.
I don't remember that. That
ain't me. I don't get heated.
That wasn't very monkly of me.
- I've never seen you this
angry in my life, it's so funny.
- I think I was more angry here than I was
breaking in your videos Joey.
- What's the next clip?
- There Are Too Many Sabers in Fate.
- We're just talking about the series.
We haven't gotten into Fate law itself.
- We're not getting into that.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah this podcast will
be, almost a Fate podcast.
- This was the moment when
Conner was like, "I'm done."
- Conner was like "No, we
are stopping this topic."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah we need
to do something, anything,
literally anything, but
this topic, anything.
Please, I beg of you.
- This next one is my personal favorite,
School Days Is A Masterpiece
of Our Generation.
- Episode three I believe it was.
- Yeah. One of our early ones.
- It's so funny that you
say it like the school days,
like now is either like a 10 or a two.
I was definitely one of those
people who put it as a 10.
- I know you did, you piece of shit.
(Joey laughing)
'Cause, 'Cause I know exactly what my-
- What is going on here?
- God, look how bad the
studio was back then.
- I think this is the first time we ever
got heated on the podcast.
Yeah, it didn't take us
long, three episodes.
(laughing)
- Three episodes? What were we doing
for the first two episodes?
- Who knows?
- I don't know.
- Being civil? Were we civil
in the first two episodes?
I guess we were.
- Yeah I mean this, this
is a classic moment for me.
- I like this one.
Yeah. This was, I'm still
proud of this moment.
- This is a-
still an awful opinion.
Awful, awful, opinion.
- It is awful. Terrible.
Despicable frankly.
- And I don't know why he has
a job judging other people's
mouths when this exists, right?
- I'm clearly not fit for the job.
Next one is Bowling is Boring.
- It is dude. This is, I was
very passionate about this.
- I remember this one actually.
I still am very passionate about this.
- Play the clip.
- Bowling is like the most
depressing activity out of
all of the activities.
- Really?
- I think so.
- I feel like bowling with
alcohol is fine. It's fine.
But bowling without alcohol is boring.
(laughing)
- Describes a 95% of activities.
- Why did you sound so unsure?
You're like bowling is-
Is it boring? I think?
- I think cause I just realized
I was just like talking shit.
- You weren't talking
shit, you were saying it.
- It was like, he was like, yeah,
the floor is made out of floor.
(laughing)
It was kind of that moment-
- Then sentence was generating
as it came out of your mouth.
I'm pretty sure I just
auto-generated that sentence.
I, I was like moving my mouth.
That was like text to speech.
(laughing)
- No, no. It's like the phone
auto predict an activity,
Bowling is an activity which is bowling.
And finally, The Dragonball
Fan base is the Worst.
- I love this clip.
- You just see the dumbest take.
It's always from a Dragonball
avatar or like someone who
like just tweets about Dragonball Yeah.
- It's still a true up. I
think out of everything.
This was the most rantiest episode of all.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause we're like, no, no
one was safe that episode.
- We were like, "If we're
going to shit on one fan base,
we're shitting on everything".
- We literally shit on
like every anime fan base
that existed.
- It makes it it if everyone
is rich, then nobody is broke.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Exactly.
- I think honestly that's my favorite.
That was my favorite to film
in terms of just ranting about
different things.
- I 100% I think that's going to win.
- I don't think that's going to win.
- [Joey] I don't think
that's going to win.
- Because I feel like that
was just an entire episode
of ranting and you couldn't like,
the Dragon Ball one stood out the most,
but yeah, we could've,
we could've put any kind moment in there.
- I genuinely believe the
saber one is gonna win.
- Really?
- I have a feeling.
- I have feel The Great
Burger Debate is gonna win.
- Mmm, I have a feeling the
saber one is going to win.
- [Garnt] It's either going
to be Great Burger Debate
or School Days
- I feel the Great Burger Debate is going
to be powered by the
Men in Motel animated,
'cause that went quite viral.
But it's only one way to find
out, I guess let's do it.
Trash Taste Awards Best Rant
(drum roll)
goes to The Great Burger Debate.
- Whoo!
(Clapping)
- Again, not surprised there.
- I mean, it's, it's hard to nail down-
- You went off!
- It's hard to nail down
a more like one of like,
I mean there's so many
iconic clips, right?
The Greg Burger Debate is an iconic clip
for just Trash Taste in general.
- It's still wrong in general.
- Yeah, no because for how right he is.
- No, no, no.
I like, I like-
- Clown shit.
- I like how it, whenever,
whenever like someone
outside of the podcast
hangs out with us,
they get surprised that we do
the actual, the actual things
that we say on the podcast.
- Yeah were like, "I thought
the Hamburger thing was a bit."
You you actually like it?
- I remember the first time,
like I remember the first time
we were interviewing Ashley and
we were at the Dennys and
I ordered a hamburger,
and Conner gives me the most
evil look and Ashley's like,
"Oh, this was real?"
(laughing)
"You guys actually do this shit?"
- We do, we do.
- "This isn't just for
entertainment purposes?"
- Yeah, but I remember like
when Ken came on as well,
like we, we went, we went to like a,
went to an Italian restaurant afterwards
and we ordered pizza, but
I didn't eat my crust.
- And he was like, "whoa".
And Ken, Ken's producer was like,
"Oh this is, this is a thing
that you, you weren't around."
- It's a reference to Trash Taste.
- Wow it's like watching Trash Taste.
You're like that guy from
Trash Taste right now.
- What were the percentages?
- [Ashley] Great Burger Debate
won with 32.6% of the vote.
- Mm, pretty interesting.
- [Ashley] In second
place was School Days.
- Of course, yeah.
- [Ashley] With 23%.
- What came last?
- [Ashley] What came last
was Bowling is Boring.
- That's fair enough. It's
probably not as memorable
as the other ones for sure.
- Yeah. Yeah
- Not bad. Not bad.
- What's the next category Ashley?
- [Joey] Catchphrase of the Year.
- [Conner] Oh God.
- [Joey] I have a feeling I,
I know what it's going to be.
- I know this ones.
- Let's see the nominees.
- [Joey And Conner] "It hits different".
- [Garnt] "I fuck with this".
- [Joey] I'm proud of that one.
- [Joey] "X with attitude".
Again, this is attributed
to my dad not me.
- [Garnt] "I worked at the BBC".
- Classic? Is that a catch phrase or-
- Yeah its classic.
- or just, or just a thing
that, I know upstate?
- And I say that the diamond
in the rough right here,
"Why are you laughing Meilyne?"
(laughing)
- I love that we have friends
that literally like text her
and it goes to Garnt, like,
"Garnt do you work at the BBC?"
Everyone jokes to Garnt
about working at the BBC
because he says it so fucking much.
- Like off, off camera
this probably is like the,
probably the biggest in joke
within our like friend group.
- Yeah a 100%.
- In terms of the iconic catch phrase-
- I think this completely
goes down to like
how much it was memed, and
how often we actually say it.
- Right.
- And I feel-
- I mean, it hits
different hits different.
- It hits different or-
- I mean, I know we say that a lot.
- We didn't invent it though.
- Yeah we didn't invent it either.
I would say the one that we
say the most that we invented
was "X with attitude", right?
- Hmm. Right. Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean, I've,
I've liked I've I think
I've been hanging out
with Joey too much cause
I I've started to say,
I fuck with this more often.
(Joey laughs)
- Really?
- And like you know,
- Oh no.
- You know that phrase that you
start off saying ironically,
- Yeah
- because you want to, like,
you want to like, yeah,
- Joke.
- you want to joke around and
then it's turns into like,
"oh, I'm just saying
this all the time now."
That's me with "I fuck with this".
- What can I say? I'm a trendsetter.
(laughing)
- There's a doubt on that one.
- Oh my God. I mean,
honestly I probably think
it's going to be, "It hits different".
- I mean, it hits different.
- But it's going to be
bittersweet if that wins.
- I think it won't win actually.
- Really?
- I feel it could be something else.
- I'm hoping like the
black horse right here is
the "Why are you laughing Meilyne?"
I really hope.
- Meilyne's favorite.
- Yeah I really hope this wins.
Yeah. So let's find out Garnt.
- You have the award card?
Let us know who wins.
- Let's find out. Find out.
This will forever solidify-
(drum roll)
- Okay the catch phrase of the year is-
Is "It hits different".
- It hit different!
I mean it do hit different though.
- I am a little sad because I
do feel like it's so generic
and not. We didn't make it
so it's a bit sad that that one won.
- It's bitter sweet, but
we appreciate you guys
for (indistinct).
- Does that mean we
have to come with a new
catchphrase for next year?
- Yes. Yeah. Every year we
need a new catchphrases.
- We need a new catch phrase.
- What was the percentages?
- [Ashley] "It's a
different" won with 49.7%.
- Fucking Hell, that was a landslide.
- Not even close.
- Yeah not even close.
- Second place?
- [Ashley] In second place
with 21.4% of the vote
is "Why are you laughing Meilyne?"
(laughing)
- Ahh there it was!
- Yeah there we go.
- At least it got, at least it got second.
At least it got something.
- It got so close.
Oh man.
- What was after that?
- [Ashley] Third place was,
"I worked for the BBC".
(clapping)
- I got to find somewhere else to work
so we can start a new catchphrase.
- [Ashley] I apologize.
In third place, it was "X with attitude".
- Ahh. Okay. That makes more sense.
That makes more sense.
- So yeah, I'd say that makes sense.
- Makes sense. I'm a bit disappointed,
but it makes sense.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Alright.
Let's look at the next category.
Next category is Guest of the Year.
- Now we've had a lot of guests
on Trash Taste this year.
- All of them are right over there.
- Chris' one is about to fall off.
(laughing)
- When did Chris' one fall down?
- It's been like that the whole episode.
- Has it?
- Yeah.
- Since when?
(indistinct chatter)
- Leave it. Leave it.
- It's good. We good.
- Now obviously we don't,
you know it's obviously
not the nicest thing to
rank your guests in order.
- No.
- But.
- But in our hearts and everyone's hearts.
Everyone's a number one.
- Yeah. We each wanted to
see which ones you guys
liked the most actually, I
think we're just curious, and
we're very grateful for all
the guests that we've had on.
- Yeah absolutely.
- And you know-
- I guess this is less
to like rank everyone,
and more of just like awarding, you know,
awarding someone who
really left an impression
on the viewers.
- I agree, I agree.
- And that's how I see it.
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
- 'Cause I don't think we,
we haven't had a bad guest.
- No. I've enjoyed every guest.
- No absolutely not.
Everyone's been great.
- Except for Chris, I mean by the way.
(laughing)
- Well, let's look at
the nominees I guess.
Just to refresh our minds
on who we've had this year.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Jesus Christ.
Chris is gonna fucking hate you.
Chris is going to kill you, Ashley.
(Garnt laughing)
- [Conner] Ashley, you're
gonna, you're really gonna
do our boy like this?
So for context, this is from the webtoon
that's someone who's making
of us and they decided to
make Chris into this like
bowl of lard for some reason.
That's the only way to describe it really.
And yeah, Ashley was like,
"that's a perfect picture of Chris".
Chris came on episode
five, and episode 30.
- Yeah.
So he's the only one who's had two.
And then we had the lovely Shibuya Kaho.
- Yeah. And then we
had, Meilyne obviously.
- Remember being a guest on here Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I don't.
(laughing)
- Meilyne tries to forget it every day.
And then we had the queen of
degeneracy herself, Sydsnap,
come on. And then we have,
of course Mori Calliope.
- Who could forget?
- Noriyaro, Alexi.
We had Ken Arto, a
wonderfully talented Ken Arto.
And the wonderfully talented Nano as well.
- [Joey] And we had
Aki come on, Ladybeard,
and last but not least Reina Scully.
- We've had a lot of guests on.
- I did not expect ourselves
so many guests that started this.
- What's that 10 guests?
- Well. Yeah. I think because, you know,
because the borders haven't been open,
we haven't really been able to get
a lot of international guests on.
- I'm honestly surprised
we got as many as we did.
- Yeah honestly. 'Cause
I thought with, you know,
the world situation being the way it was,
that we would be really really limited
with the guests that we could find.
- Yeah because what is that one every,
one out of five episodes
was a guest episode.
- And I, you know,
people always, you know,
there was complaining being like,
"oh, you should just waive
the rule for X, X situation".
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like, no, it's like, I dunno.
I think to us, it's like the, the, the,
the importance of Trash Taste is
getting to be with them in
person and the chemistry,
and also getting to meet with them before,
getting to hang out with
them afterwards, you know,
making sure that it's not just a,
"Come on my show, fuck off", you know?
- Yeah like come hang out with us.
- 'Cause like every
single guest we've had,
we've really had like a
proper like connection
after their episode has aired.
- And like, I hope that conveys
to the audience as well,
because one of the biggest
things that before we decided
to have guests on is that we didn't want
to just interview our guests.
We wanted the guests to be,
you know, part of, part
of the round table.
Part of the boys.
- There's nothing better
than an in-person interaction
in my opinion.
- Probably part of my favorite
part of having a guest on
isn't just the recording of the episode.
It's just hanging out afterwards as well.
- Right.
- [Joey] Yeah absolutely.
- We just enjoy, we just enjoy hanging out
and meeting people.
- And Chris getting us violently drunk,
the normal stuff that happens
when you have Chris on.
- Of course.
- But everyone has been fantastic.
But of course they can only do one winner.
- Let's find out who the
viewers have voted for.
- Yes.
I'm. I'm, I'm curious if
it will be a correlation
of views on the episode to the guest.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but we'll have a look.
It's gonna be interesting. Let's find out.
(drum roll)
- The Guest of the Year as
voted by the viewers is-
- Fuck off!
- [Joey] What?
- Open it up.
Get this shit out. Get this shit out.
- My man Chris Broad.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Get this shit out of here.
- The secret fourth member of Trash Taste.
(laughing)
- Oh my God. Cockroach of the year.
We can't fucking get rid of him.
- Was the percentage was
probably fucking ridiculous.
Wasn't it?
- [Ashley] He won with 37.2%.
- That's quite a lot considering
the amount of guests.
- That's pretty high considering
there was 10 nominees.
- Can't believe Chris fucking won.
- That means Chris has won
Best Guest and Laziest Drip.
- And Biggest, No I was the Biggest Clown.
I wish it was it was Chris.
- He was the greatest guest, but God damn
was his closet game weak.
- Maybe Chris will be in the running for
the biggest clown next year.
- Next year, next year.
- Yeah. I bet next
episode Chris is going to
fucking rock up. Suit,
blazer, and the works.
I hope he does. I hope.
(laughing)
- Whenever Chris is next door. Yeah.
- When he inevitably comes
on. I'm sure he will.
- When he inevitably comes on.
- We don't have a
choice. He just turns up.
- It's like dun, dun, dun.
- Yeah on Tuesdays. He just turns up.
Like, " what's going on lad?"
- It's like "well fuck."
- I think that was the
last recording. Right?
He just texted us one day and
was like, "Lads recording?"
Recording?
- Yeah recording.
(indistinct)
- Well I guess so Chris.
- Alright, cool.
- I loved how he was like,
"I didn't know people were gonna
watch this podcast when I first came on,
so I didn't care."
(laughing)
I think that's why he won Laziest Drip
because he turns up in
shirt a second time.
- He didn't give a fuck.
He was like, "No one's
going to watch Trash Taste,
so why would I care?"
- "This, this podcast is going to go down
after three episodes. It's fine."
- Now he's like, "Please let me back on."
- Look at us now Chris, look at us now.
- Yeah well done.
- I understand why, you know,
I think as Chris fits in
so well, it's understandable
why people love Chris.
- It's nothing but
(indistinct) with Chris.
- It's fine that we're
giving him shit now.
Now, you know, just guest shows.
- I'm sure. I'm sure
he'll give a shit now.
- But again, please go
and watch every single
guest episode that we've had on.
Every single guest has
been fucking amazing.
So shout out to you guys for helping us
make the show better.
- Yeah. Thank you.
I mean, thank you to everyone who came on.
We had a fantastic time in every episode
that we filmed so far.
And anyone, we'd love
to have you on again.
Hopefully we can add to
this wall this year as well.
- Yeah. Hope so.
- And a new wall.
- I hope this doesn't
give the impression that
we can only re-invite, Chris.
- Yeah.
- Anyone anyone is welcome to come back.
- Anyone is welcome to come back.
- Exactly.
Let's look at the next
category. Best Argument.
- [Joey] Well, I mean, we've
probably had about 50 arguments
just in this episode alone.
- Like the most heated argument
or like the most memorable.
I wonder what the view
is of choosing basically.
- Yeah right?
- Because if it's like strictly
speaking the most argument-
argument, it's gotta be
the Gacha thing, right?
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- That was by far the biggest
argument I think we had,
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- That was probably actually
an argument, I'd say.
- But I guess. Let's, let's
look at the nominees for this.
- Oh yeah we got Gacha
is Gambling, here he is.
Play the clip.
- You don't join the
Gacha Community unless you
fucking gambled a thousand
bucks and haven't got the one
with thick thighs that you
forget about three months later.
Fuck!
(laughing)
- It's true. It's true.
- It is true. And then we got
the Hamburger Debate again.
We've gone over this one.
The Crust or No Crust we've obviously got.
- Play this clown shit.
- Then Bidet or No Bidet.
- Oh I forgot about this one!
- Can we play the crust one?
- Sometimes it crumbles without the crust.
It's like the integrity of
this sandwich has been ruined.
- It's it's been optimized.
- It has not been optimized.
- You cut off all the useless pieces,
- Although-
(laughter)
- Although, and this is when it starts
to spiral out of control.
- Moments before a disaster.
(laughter)
- Play the Bidet clip.
Garnt, not realizing how lucky he is.
- I don't want a wet fucking ass.
- You don't have to be. Wipe.
That's what toilet paper was invent for.
- Then I don't want wet
fucking fingers after I wipe.
That's just-
How fucking wet is your ass?
- Are you wiping your
ass you fucking gremlin?
- To this day, I still
revisit this to this day.
'Cause it's so funny.
- I just can't believe this
man doesn't utilize the bidet.
- Just the lack of logic in
this argument was so funny.
- I mean, the thing that,
the thing about bidets is I still stand by
heated toilet seats.
Bidet I'm still just like,
if, if the toilet paper I got here,
wasn't so thin and breaks up easily,
then I would use the bidet more often.
But it's it's the wiping
afterwards that gets me mad.
It's the wiping afterwards.
- My God. Such a clown Garnt.
Were you always this much of a clown?
- I'm sorry. Who won
Biggest Clown, Conner?
I'm sorry.
(Joey laughing)
- Unjustly so I would say.
- He can't say anything.
- I would like to believe
that that is more clown shit,
then what I've said.
- We have an Uno Reverse
card ready at all times now.
(laughing)
- What do you thinks
gonna win this one boys?
- Oh God.
I mean any of these good honestly win.
Fuck man.
I genuinely have no idea.
This is one of the most
iconic things in Trash Taste,
which is our arguments.
And I feel like-
- I feel like the Gacha one is just
such an intense argument,
it's got to be the most memorable,
surely even out of those.
If you think argument.
- Yeah, I mean, it's okay.
- It's literally the Great
Burger Debate, no argument.
You know what I mean? Like the Gacha one
is a real fucking argument.
- I would say the great burger
debate was like more heated.
Quote, unquote.
The crust one was pretty heated as well.
- I guess.
- The Gacha one. I dunno like I-
- You guys should rewatch the bidet one,
'Cause that got fucking heated.
- How much heat did this one get?
- I can't remember exactly.
- It got pretty fucking heated.
- I just remember the Gacha one.
The Gacha one sticks in my
head so much, I don't know why.
- Yeah honestly like, I
mean, I look at all these
and out of all of them,
the Gacha one sticks out
as the one where I'm just like-
"Yeah I don't really agree
with what I said on that one."
I'll back peddle on that one.
- Yeah everyone had some
pretty shit taste on that one.
I guess that's what made it interesting.
But yeah again there
can only be one winner.
So Garnt.
- It's you.
- Oh it's me.
- It's you I think Garnt.
- Nope it's me, nevermind.
(laughing)
All right, here we go.
(drum roll)
Best Argument for Trash Taste Awardw is
Gacha's Gambling.
- Ahhh.
- I told you.
- That, you know what makes sense.
I think it was by far one
that made the viewers be like,
"Are they okay?"
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Are they going to be
okay after this argument?"
- Watching a friendship shatter.
- Oh yeah, that was the case, wasn't it?
- All the other ones were
you know, were hehe funny,
but that was the one where
we got so many comments
of people like, "Oh god,
are they going to be okay?"
- We were okay, don't worry guys
(laughing)
- We are still friends. We are all good.
- 'Cause I commented, "Guys,
guys, seriously, it's chill."
It's chill, chill. Don't worry.
It's fine.
- We were just in it.
- They were getting so worried because
we were all really going at it.
- What were the percentages on that?
- [Ashley] Gacha's Gambling
won with 36.2% of the vote.
- 36.2%
- [Ashley] In second place was
the Steak Debate with 24.4%.
- Okay.
- Oh.
- Okay, okay.
- [Ashley] Crust or No Crust
came in third with 23.4 %
- Bidet one was last.
- It's because I feel they came in last
because not many, not enough
people have experienced
the bidet, to have an opinion on it.
- True, true, true.
- I personally advocate
for the bidet clip though.
It's so funny.
- It is a good clip.
- It's so funny.
- Yeah.
- All right. What's the
next category Ashley?
- Best Trash Taste Special.
I guess we did leave this one in.
I thought we cut this one
out, but I guess we did leave
in the Trash Taste Special.
- I guess we left it in.
- There's only three-
- Wow, Garnt don't you look
like a clown right now, huh.
(Garnt indistinct)
- Uno Reverse card.
- Now we're already
getting nominations ready
for this next one.
- Look at this try-hard.
- It's the new season Garnt.
This counts as the next year.
You can already be nominated.
- Get the nominations ready guys.
(laughing)
- I guess there's only
three nominees for this one,
but let's, let's check it out.
- I'm actually curious
to see which one people
liked the most.
I would say. Cause people
voting on this must be,
I would say the, the more like
dedicated Trash Taste fans.
- [Joey] Oh yeah yeah
yeah. Hundred percent.
- As opposed to like the casual ones.
I'm curious to see
which ones they'll pick.
- [Joey] So we obviously
that our first one was the
Chess Tournament Arc.
- [Garnt] Yeah The Chess
Tournament which was insane.
And then we got the Trash
Taste Real Tokyo Drifting.
And then the Cycling Across Japan Special.
- I like all of these
for their own reasons.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I think that the best
story is the chess one.
- [Joey] A hundred percent.
- I think the most fun
to film was the drifting.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then I think the cycling
one showcases our chemistry.
- I feel cycling, we definitely
like perfected like how
Trash Taste Specials go.
- We learned a lot from
the drifting special.
- We did.
- And like, I don't know if
we've already mentioned this,
but by far the best thing
about this was having
the walkie talkies, because
how boring this would have been
if we didn't have the walkie talkies?
- Hundred percent. Hundred percent.
- I feel like the, the
drifting one to me was
a proof of concept to be like, okay,
Trash Taste is cool, but
can we take this outside
and bring the same chemistry?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I also, think that the
thumbnail is like the best one.
I made that thumbnail.
I love it. It's so good.
- They're all great thumbnails honestly.
And they're all great videos, but yeah.
- This one you liked, like
we've already said I'm,
I'm like surprised how much
the stars aligned for this one.
- This one was a real script.
- This one- I mean I
love all of them. Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, they're all great.
- There are a lot of people who watch
the Trash Taste podcast who
don't watch the specials.
Please do. Please consider watching.
- Please check it out. We
put so much work into these
and it's fully backed by the patrons.
- Yeah. It's really fully done.
Like honestly we try to get it
as close to like TV quality.
- Honestly. I think the biggest thing is
we try to get it as close to TV quality
without having a TV crew behind us.
- It's just a couple of
cameramen, that's all.
- You do not know the fucking
logistics that went into
filming this one.
Oh my God.
- We have to bust out the
blue prints for this one.
- Meilyne was lucky that
she didn't have to help
with that one.
- She would have lost her mind.
- Truly, truly Hell on Earth.
But I guess without further
ado Garnt, let's find out
which Trash Taste Special-
- There is only one.
- And-
(drum roll)
The Best Trash Taste
Special of the Year goes to-
The Cycling Special.
- Well deserved.
(clapping)
- I'm not surprised.
- Well deserved.
- If I was a betting
man. I would put cycling,
drifting, chess would be the order.
- Yeah. Is it cycling, drifting chess?
- [Ashley] It is cycling, drifting, chess.
- Yeah. What is the percentage?
- [Ashley] Cycling won with 60.1%.
- Wow. 60.1.
- That's the biggest margin
we've had of any of these.
60.1.
- I mean, I, I was like,
I was honestly surprised because
after the drifting special,
I was like, this is our Magnum Opus.
I don't think we can stop this.
- I don't know, man. 'Cause
it took us like what?
15 drafts to get something that was good.
Like we had so many drafts
that sucked and I was like,
Oh God, is this video just
bad and are we fucked?
- 'Cause I knew when we were filming.
I think when we switched off the cameras,
I knew we would film the banger.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But then like, what I didn't realize was
how much of the editing we
would have to put into it,
to like convey the feeling
that I felt when I was filming.
- Big, big shout out to
Mudan once again, man.
Like he fucking brought
this video to life.
- Honestly, MVP of the
specials. Mudan, not us.
- Not honestly.
- We just, we just show up
and we just do random shit.
- I wouldn't say that man.
There's a lot of planning
that we had to do that was fucking hell.
- True.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Our bikes were a monstrosity
of cables and batteries.
- All the cameraman then
helped us out as well-
- The amount of times I
had to rewatch the cycling
special it's like create a
coherent narrative out of this
because 'cause it was just like so all-
like the first draft was
so all over the place,
and trying to like weave
that into something
that you guys could follow
was probably the biggest
challenge I've had all year actually.
- Alright let's find out
what the next category is.
- [Joey] Best Trash Taste Moment
Oh this is in general.
- Let's have a look at the nominees
of the Best Trash Taste Moment.
- God, there's so many to choose from.
Oh this is, this is when this is when
it gets really, really fucking hard.
(laughing)
- I love how the first
two are from the Hentai-
- We don't actually need to play
because you've already played them.
- I mean, I feel like
when, when we made this,
this was just like the highlight
reel of some of the best
moments that had gotten
nominated from other categories.
- We obviously we've got the
Kuroinu Orc Gaming Debate,
Conner's Mother Knows Breast Debate,
Rias Solo Carrying Garnt's
Figure Challenge Win,
The Great Burger Debate,
- Uh, page two,
- Me Coming Out Moment,
Meilyne's Three By Three,
and Bidet Debate.
That rolls off the
tongue, the Bidet Debate.
- I don't even know. Honestly,
I, I I'm, I'm I'm biased,
- [Joey] Fuck man.
- Mother Knows Breast has a
special place in my heart.
- Honestly, any of these could win, man.
- I, it's like picking
between your children.
The it's this is way too hard for me.
There's so many iconic moments
that have happened throughout
the year. And none of these were planned.
- [Joey] Yeah exactly.
- I I'd say the only
one out of all of these
that we knew what was coming was the,
Kuroinu Orc Gangbang Debate 'cause I knew-
- 'Cause we, we planned that.
- I knew, I knew.
- We were gonna lose our
fucking minds over that.
And we did it's an to
a great, like it was,
it was one of the moments
where I knew something
was going to happen. And
I'm glad that it kind of
lived up to what was going
to happen in my mind.
- Definitely.
- God, I guess there's only
one way to find out really.
- Should we just start?
I really don't know.
- This is one of the biggest awards.
The viewers decided for the
Best Trash Tastes Moment,
of I guess, 2020-2021,
Season 2020-21 I guess-
- Season One. Just keep,
just keep it simple.
- The Best Moment of Season
One of Trash Taste is-
(drum roll)
Can we get a drum roll in post-Mudan?
It is, oh, it's upside down.
(laughing)
- What does it Moonlight? Finding Nemo?
The Best Trash Tastes Moment of the Year
Season one is-
Connor's Mother Knows Breast Debate.
(Cheering)
- Wow, really?
- Wow.
- I'm not surprised because
that is the one that
to this day, I still get
people talking to me about.
People always talk to me
about Mother Knows Breast
and I feel like it's such a visceral clip.
It's such a like, oh God.
- That's not a clip you
can share with the family.
- No, no, no. I mean, I'm
not surprised that one won
if I'm honest.
- I love how the Best Moment
is Mother Knows Breast.
- When they all played, I'm like, yeah,
I think this one's gonna win.
- 'Cause all the other one's
are good, don't get me wrong,
but none of them give
you a reaction like that
at least from the viewer's perspective.
- What was the percentage on this one?
- [Ashley] This one won with 19.8.
- Whoo, it's close.
- 19.8%. That's so close.
- And what was second place?
- [Ashley] Kuroinu Orc GangBang Debate.
(laughing)
- Of course.
- [Ashley] 18.3%
- 18.3 %
- One percent off.
- That was one percent
off the Hentai episode.
- Oh my God.
- I wonder if that'll be a little hint
as to what might win Best Episode.
- Yeah.
- Maybe.
- I don't know. People clearly
liked the Hentai episode.
- Yeah. Wow.
- What came third?
- [Ashley] Third was
Joey's Coming Out Moment.
- Wow.
- What an amazing moment, amazing moment.
- I'm glad, I'm glad I did that.
Yeah. Wow.
All right.
And last but not least we
have one more category left,
but before we get into
that, we have to give
some shout outs to you guys.
- Yep.
- And that's all the people
who sent us fan edits
and fan art because the
sub Reddit and the Twitter
wouldn't be where it is without you guys.
And there've been some
fucking amazing fan edits
and fan art that we've received.
- Here's just like a
tiny amount that Ashley
found in 10 minutes.
- Honestly, this is just, yeah.
- Ashley, next slide, please.
(laughing)
- This is just like a,
really really tiny portion
of the fan edits and fan art,
fan, everything that we got.
- Play some on screen right
now while we're talking.
- Here's here's a hot,
here's a highlight reel of
everything that came out.
- Yeah while we talk yeah about
fan art and how good it is.
And thank you so much.
And we, we couldn't just one.
Because there was just
so many and they're all
just so amazing in different ways.
And we really, really are like grateful.
We're always like whenever
we hang out or just chatting,
we're like, "yo, do you see
this piece of sick fan art?"
- Yeah
- Send it to each other. So
again, we all really, really,
we really do appreciate
it and keep 'em coming.
- And I do have a surprise for you boys.
- [Joey] What?
- Oh shit what?
- Do you wanna bring it out Meilyne?
- Wow. What is it?
I'm scared.
- So I, you know, it
wouldn't, it wouldn't feel it-
- What the fuck is this?
- What the fuck is that?
- [Ashley] Am I coming out? Okay I guesso.
- Okay, Ashley. I guess
you'll bring it out.
- [Meilyne] Ashley is better dressed.
- Just give it to Garnt.
- [Joey] What the fuck is this?
- What the fuck is this?
- So like, it wouldn't feel
right having the viewers,
you know, having to like narrow down
all of the fan edits
and fan art that we got,
but I felt like the fairest
way was just to look on Reddit.
- Right.
- And see what was, what did,
what did the community
vote as like the one
that was like most memorable
was like the top voted
fan art candidates.
And so I got it framed for you boys.
(laughing)
- Ah ha, no way.
- So this was, unfortunately,
this was second
just behind my Laughing at
Corona Moments on our subreddit.
But this was the highest rated fan edit
that was voted on this year.
- I remember when I spoke with
this at my meme review video,
I was like, look at the Garnt's hands.
'Cause I'm the only one in this
picture who is actually me.
Your bodies are someone else.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
- These are the veiniest
fucking hands of all the time.
- Look at this man's hands.
- [Joey] Garnt like I
don't know, he drank,
he drank the ooze or
something like he's like,
he's mutating .
- These are the hands
of a man who's choked
a hundred people.
- [Joey] That's like some Thanos hands.
- It's weird.
- It's like pro gamer hands man.
- [Joey] It's a pro gamer picture!
- Oh my God.
- [Joey] I fucking love this art.
- I do love this picture.
- I guess from this point on
with every year we're going to
be framing the highest top voted one .
- Yeah. The highest voted.
- I mean, I guess I wanted
to surprise your boys
'cause I'm just like,
I feel like since we're
moving studio soon, I, I want
it to have something for us
to remember season one by.
- [Joey] That's so cool, I love that.
- And this is, this is
going to be our memorabilia.
- Well thank you Garnt.
(clapping)
- Oh yeah, that's fucking awesome.
- Oh my God.
- That's such a nice -.
We dead ass didn't know that was coming.
Holy shit.
- Can you get the
champagne as well Meilyne?
And I think,
I think it's time to get the
champagne out before our-
- Before we talk about the
Best Episode of Trash Taste
that we gotta, we gotta
crack open a bottle-
- [Joey] Oh absolutely.
- To celebrate.
- Exactly. This is a
celebration after all.
- I wonder, I don't know.
What, what did you guys
think going into Trash Taste?
Like what did you think was gonna happen?
When you join a podcast I feel-
like we've all been on a podcast.
We don't have the
podcast experience. Yeah.
So I wasn't, I wasn't
expecting that, exactly.
But I wasn't expecting anything different.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah absolutely.
- I wasn't excited anything
crazy either though.
- I think the biggest thing
is that obviously none of us
expected for Trash Taste
to be this successful.
- [Joey] No.
- Because we were, I remember
when we were planning this,
the reason our studio
is so small right now,
and the reason we were
moving into a new one,
is because we were literally just paying
for this out of pocket. And we, you know,
we didn't know how successful, or
if this was even going to make
money within the first year.
Like I remember-
- Put in a fuck ton of our
own money just to feel like,
"We think this can work,
let's give it a chance."
- I remember, like I keep
saying this on episodes,
but I remember still during
the first week or two,
when Garnt and I would be like,
"Be nice if we could hit a
100k by the end of the year.
And now approaching this
one year anniversary,
we are almost at a million!
- That's crazy.
- This is the end of the year.
- Just fucking nuts.
- I mean, I can't believe
we're just approaching
a fucking million. Right? That's insane.
- I think it's safe to say that we kind of
like underestimated the
potential of a podcast. Right?
- I mean, I remember before
we even started this podcast,
we looked at some of the other
competition out there. Right?
And we were just like, okay, here's,
here's a reasonable estimate
of where we might end up.
And it turns out we were just like five,
like 10 places too lower than
what we thought we were going
to where we thought we were going to be.
I guess before we unveil the
last award, we'd like to say,
we'd like to say a few
words. If that's cool.
- Shall I crack this open now or before?
- Go ahead now before crack
it, crack it open now.
- Crack it open now!
Pop the champagne baby!
(cork pops)
We're known,
we're known for talking shit a lot but-
- Congratulations!
if we could get real for a second, Joey,
just wanted to say something to you.
- Okay.
Like before, you know,
you are one of my best mates
before we started this podcast and-
- And now you're not.
(laughs)
- And like, like especially
being on this podcast every week
and just sitting next to you every week
discussing all that of our shit,
fucking like blows my mind
how similar we are sometimes.
(Joey laughs)
Like it's, it's, it's fucking insane
that sometimes you say
something, I have a thought,
I'm not just like, God damn it Joey,
- I was gonna say that.
- Stop being the same person as me.
And it's, it's gotten,
it's gotten so much.
I think we've just like
kind of assimilated,
our like nuances and everything,
which you can see by the amount
of clips we have of just me
and Joey being in sync.
- Syncing up.
- Like that. It's not just
what happens when you sit next
to your best mate for life.
- We both took the red pill and-
(laughing)
- Fully assimilated.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
And like, I couldn't be happier
to be sitting across you.
One of you having like you
as a co guest, co-host sorry.
- Absolutely. Man. Gonna
make me fucking cry bro.
- Conner.
- My heart, my heart.
Conner, I know you were like
fucking nervous as when,
before starting this podcast.
- I was, I was.
- Because I know like
compared to me and Joey
you're you are, I like, you
were like, you weren't small,
but you're like way less
established than you were, than us.
- You know.
- This is true.
- I was very concerned about that as well.
- And I know you were concerned
coming into the podcast
that people would just be like,
"Who the fuck is this guy?"
- "I want anime. Who is this guy?"
- Who is this guy? He does
like Black Butler fandom,
Like who the fuck is this guy? You know?
But like, I couldn't be more proud of you
as a mate to see how much you've grown
in the last year. I've done.
No, because like, I, I think,
I think out of everyone
you've like grown the most,
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- You have Trash Taste
and you've definitely like
established yourself.
And like you know, like,
you know, as a mate,
I couldn't be fucking proud of you.
- Come on. Give me a hug Garnt.
- Aww.
(clapping)
- Oh, I'm sure you hugged too.
- And everybody clapped.
- And I guess the last thanks
I want to give is to Meilyne.
- Yay!
(clapping)
- Honestly, Mei-
we wouldn't be here
without Meilyne, honestly.
Yeah. Me and Conner would
not be here in Japan.
And you did a fucking like,
I know you told the story about
how you just brought us here
because it was like a company competition,
but I couldn't be more thankful
that you basically just
created the boys, Meilyne.
- Yeah.
- Do you wanna come on camera?
- [Meilyne] No.
(laughs)
- Come on, you're nicely
dressed. Come on, Meilyne.
- Everyone claps for Meilyne.
(clapping)
Everyone give a round
of applause to Meilyne.
Take a bow Meilyne.
[Meilyne] I had to buy this outfit.
(laughing)
- That's why you bought the outfit.
- Yeah aren't you glad you
didn't come in a t-shirt?
And be like "yeah I made the boys."
(laughing)
- Yeah. And I guess, I
guess last, but not last,
I guess off the Meilyne
is obviously you guys.
I mean, we have just talked about how
we did not expect the audience
that we were going to get.
And I certainly didn't expect
to have an audience that was
like this dedicated.
The subreddit is a lot more
popular than I thought we were
going to be. The meme are fantastic.
The fan arts, fantastic.
The animation, the
animations are fantastic.
You guys are just fantastic.
- Just how dedicated you guys
are to just ask rambling every
week for two hours,
it's just fucking nuts.
And I think like biggest
thing more than anything,
it really gave me personally,
a lot of confidence in
just me as a person.
- [Conner] Yeah me too, me too.
- Like completely separate
from my personality.
And like, I dunno, that's
like, it feels great, right?
It's like, oh, I'm getting
validated for just being me.
And there's no better
feeling than that. So yeah.
God, it feels,
it sounds like we're about
to like end the podcast.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(laughter)
- Here's our final episode guys.
- It's nice man. I feel like,
you know, you, you already
feel like you've made friends for life.
I really do. I'm very
lucky to have, you know,
you guys. I'm very very grateful.
- I'm really happy as well.
Let's all get our hands
off our dicks and get
get to the final-
- Back to shit talking.
Back to shit talking
with the final category.
- The Best Episode of Trash Taste.
Now, obviously we have taken
out any other guest episodes
because the guests are on a
completely different caliber.
This is just the boys
chatting as the boys do.
- Honestly, we kind of
pick these episodes.
So this was nominations
nominations for so many,
so many episodes. So we were just like,
what were the funnest ones
for us to film? So this,
this not only is like our
favorite episode, hopefully,
you know, one of our favorite episodes,
but these are the episodes
that we want you guys to
personally go check out.
Cause these are the ones that
we personally love, but yeah,
let's check out the nominees.
All right. So How to
NOT Buy Anime Figures.
I remember filming this
episode and this was the first
episode that I filmed and
I was like, holy shit.
I didn't know being on
camera could be that fun.
(laughing)
- Because that was one of the first, like
times where you were like
fully, fully like outside.
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah, fucking Hell.
- Just the, just, just
the Rias Solo Carrying
the performance and just like the,
this was the first one
where I look back at it
and I'm just like, man, that was,
that was a banger episode.
- One of the things though,
when we had all our videos ready to go
and the episode wasn't out
that we, I think we were
definitely like, I think we've just done
like a genius, big brain play.
- Yeah, we did.
- We really did.
- We were like, I would have went live.
- Even though I remember I fell asleep,
I didn't schedule my video
on time, so this whole thing
had like three videos on our own channels
to go up at the same time.
- Yeah.
- And I, I was asleep and
I forgot to schedule it.
So when both those videos when
up, I got so many messages
angry, like "where's Connor's part?"
And I panic and worked up later.
- Yeah. Like a cumulatively
between the episode
and our three individual episodes,
I think this amassed like 9 million views,
10 million views or something,
which is fucking nuts.
- It's fucking insane.
- Crazy.
I really do think that this was
the episode that really shot
Trash Taste up and put
us on the map. Basically.
- [Joey] Definitely.
- It pushed a lot of our
audience who maybe weren't too,
you know, you can say,
check out my new channel.
It's like, well so does
everyone. Everyone fucking does.
To actually give them an
incentive to go check it out.
And then, you know, maybe stick around.
- I feel like this was
the difference between
our core fan base being like, oh,
it's my favorite big YouTubers
collabing together to
Oh, they actually make really
funny and good content. Right?
- 'Cause this was, I was
really proud of this episode.
- Me too, me too.
- And how it turned out.
- [Joey] And then we got episode 12,
which is the College Horror Stories,
which I personally fucking love it.
- [Connor] It's just
like a comfort episode.
I like this one.
- To me, to me, this has like a,
in terms of like density of great stories.
This one's a fucking badass.
- True, true.
- I just had so many good stories.
- So much weird happens in college, right?
It's like calling for content.
- I remember like going, like
before going on this episode,
I was like, maybe I'll have, like,
I have like a clue of what
I'm going to talk about.
And then they go on it.
And then so many different
stories just like flood back in.
- Flood back in, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, oh,
I forgot that happened.
- This was the one episode
that made me regret,
not living in a dorm.
(laughing)
- Dude you get such insane stories.
- I was like fuck.
I wish I lived in the dorm
after hearing your guys stories.
- Anyone who is deciding to
go to college, go to the dorm.
The life stories and experiences
you get will be worth it.
- And then we have episode 16,
The Worst Fandoms in
Anime, the one where we-
- It's a personal favorite of
ours, probably not the fandom
but this yeah this is one we love.
- Yeah. This was fucking so fun to film.
And I'm sad that it didn't
get nominated for more other
categories because he was just so fun
ranting about being in the
anime community, which we are.
Right. And I feel like
that's why not many people
like think about this or remember it,
but like me personally,
I remember this episode,
whenever I want to rant about
anything that's going on in
the anime community.
- [Connor] Look how we had
two best episodes back-to-back
16 and then 17.
- [Joey] Oh, The Japanese
Food You Never Tried episode.
I fucking love this.
- This is fucking amazing.
- This is where the wine
meme came from as well.
- Oh this episode.
- This episode, yeah.
- This episode is just iconic.
- I can't believe it
took us like 17 episodes
to argue about food.
And then this, this just
like opened the flood gates.
And after this episode we
couldn't stop talking about food.
- This feels like episode seven.
I was like, what are we
doing for 16 episodes?
Like arguing about food
is like an iconic part
of Trash Taste. And it took 17
episodes for that to happen.
It does not feel like 17
And then of course we have
the infamous episode, 25.
- I love the Hentai episodes.
- Oh, I love it too.
- I just think there's just like,
we nailed everything in there.
Like we hit all the beats,
just like I, we, we, we, that, that,
that episode perfectly showed
our personalities I think.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Definitely.
- Food porn.
- Food porn, for better or worse.
For better or worse.
- That, that episode to me,
like filmed that episode was so fun
because not only was like
everyone on their A-game,
but we were just bouncing each other,
bouncing off each other so perfectly.
Like I remember filming this,
filming this episode and being like, wow,
we really are drift compatible.
(laughing)
- Man our horoscopes really do align.
- [Joey] And then we have
episode, what numbers that?
- [Conner] Roasting Our
Horrible Anime Tastes.
- We like to say that
we're not an anime podcast,
but Goddamn was this fun to film.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- I think we're a podcast
that just happens to have
three people who watch
a fuck ton of anime.
- Or used to watch a fuck ton of anime.
- And who like to talk
about it occasionally.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And I mean, to me, this
was just really fun to film.
And just like, I just, the Meilyne moment
was just like the cherry on top.
- Oh yeah, very good.
- Like I feel like out of everyone,
this one ended ended on the biggest bang
of just Meilyne really
revealing her degeneracy
that just came out of fucking nowhere.
And we revived the three
by three trend as well.
Which I,
- Yeah, fucking nuts.
- Which I guess we'll be doing
more of in future, I guess.
- Yeah. I mean, it's just,
it's just a great format
to judge tier lists.
- Three by three is back,
bring back the three by threes.
- Ahh man.
- But we can only choose one.
- The viewers can only choose one.
And this is biggest one of all.
- I mean, I narrowed it
down to six personally.
And how'd you guys choose the top one?
- I feel like if you're a-
I feel like the hentai episode
perfectly sums up Trash Taste.
- I feel like that.
- I feel like that could-
I will be surprised if it's not that
just because it's so visceral,
you see that you see that title.
I mean, it's like you react.
- Yeah.
- It's Simple is Best, right?
When it comes to the titles.
- It is man, it's like,
oh, the other ones, you
know, maybe you skipped it,
but you didn't skip the Hentai episode.
No, one's skipped that one.
- Nope. Everyone watched it.
I do- all my homies
watched the Hentai episode.
- I do feel like if you
want to sell someone
on Trash Taste, people
are just going to show
the Hentai episode just to be
like, "what, what is Trash Taste?"
- It does sum it up pretty well.
It's obviously not the episode.
You can't show your
friend who is not really
into that kind of stuff.
But if they're chill with
us, show 'em that episode.
But maybe we'll see, we'll
see. I don't know who won.
- By the way, I think
every episode deserves it.
But again, you guys decided on it.
- Drum roll, please Mudan.
- This is the ultimate winner.
So the final award for
The Trash Taste Awards,
(drum roll)
the First Annual Trash Taste Awards,
Best Episode for season one goes to-
the Hentai episode.
(cheering)
- Yes, yes! Well deserved! Well deserved.
What a banger! What a banger.
- Well done us. Well done.
- Let's all give each other medals.
- Congratulations Garnt. Congratulations.
- Congratulations Connor. Congratulations.
- Congratulations Joey. Congratulations.
- Great work guys, really great work.
- You know, who's awesome? You're awesome.
You're awesome as well.
- You got it, you got it, you got it!
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- I'm curious though,
what was the percentage?
- What was the final percentage?
- [Ashley] This won with
the 34.6% of the vote.
- Okay.
- And second?
- [Ashley] Second place
with 19% of the vote was
How to NOT to Buy Anime Figurines.
- Okay. Yeah.
- I guess I guess people do remember.
- I thought the Japanese food
one would've been up there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- But again, like, yeah.
Every episode was an
absolute fucking banger,
or we wouldn't upload it.
- What?
(laughing)
- You guys don't even know how
many episodes I thought were
weaker than others. But there
weren't any episodes where
I thought, "Oh we did a bad job".
I was like, that's not as good.
But sometimes you need the
mundane to make you appreciate
the really good ones that come along.
Ya know? 'Cause we don't
do shit every week.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- In the future, there will be episodes
that you might think,
"Oh, they're not really
talking about anything interesting."
We record every week.
That's going to happen.
- Yeah. That's like real life. Right?
- [Connor] Yeah true, true.
- Like, you know what mate
comes to you every week
with like a banger of story?
Right? Not everyone does.
- I mean, I feel like honestly,
Trash Taste just represents
our friendship off camera
as well because sometimes it,
it gets weird after having
recorded this for a full year.
Or you have a conversation,
I have a conversation with
one of these two and I can't remember if
I've had this conversation
on Trash Taste or
off Trash Taste.
- It like blends into reality.
- It does! Now I'm just
like, "Wait, did I already
tell you this story?"
I can't remember anymore.
- And you go "Oh yes, I
did share this story".
- But yeah. I mean, wow.
- I don't even know what to say, man.
- Well, I've, I've said
everything that I managed to say.
- I'm very grateful for
everything. You know,
some great mates grateful that
the channel is doing so well.
- Thank you guys for an entire year.
It's been fucking insane.
And man, there's plenty
more where that came from.
- Yeah I mean, again, like we're moving
to the new studio soon,
so we're hoping to, spruce this up.
- That's going to be like
the real end of season one.
- Yeah that'll be the end of season one.
- There'll be a bunch of
episodes after this one goes up,
but the real- exactly it's the OVAs
the real the season two
starts at the (indistinct)
- It's like the Spider-Man
movie after, you know,
after what was it off
of like Avengers movie.
Like, this is the real end of phase three.
(laughing)
- Okay. Okay mom.
Yeah. Guys, hopefully you
enjoyed this episode and yeah,
there is again, plenty
more where that came from.
- There's a, I mean, I
don't think Trash Taste
could be done without
the beautiful patrons.
- I mean, look at them all.
- My God.
- So many of you came
after the degeneracy,
that was the Hentai episode
and most of you stuck around.
- Most of you stayed, yeah.
- We do appreciate it.
- If you enjoyed this year of Trash Taste
and you'd like to continue supporting us,
then please go over to our Patreon.
patreon.com/TrashTaste
And also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But wow. Okay.
- I guess final thoughts.
What do you guys want to have next year?
- I want to do more specials.
I definitely want to do more specials.
- Yeah. It's very difficult right now.
- Yeah.
- But I'm hoping that we can, we have,
we've had one big idea,
which I'm not going to say,
that we put on the back burner
for a while because of Covid obviously,
and I hope we get a chance to do it.
- [Joey] I hope so. Yeah.
- Like the biggest thing
I'm looking forward to
is one having more specials,
because by far the
biggest limiter to having
more specialists has been COVID,
but there's, there's just,
we haven't been able to get around it.
And the fact that we've
made and managed to make the
specialist that we did with
two of them being outside was
just like the stars aligning
and having this particular week
where things were open and the
country was in a good enough
condition where we could film, you know.
I'm also looking forward to having more
international guests on.
- Yes, hundred percent.
Hopefully we start getting them soon.
- Hopefully.
And I'm also just looking
forward to like more kind of
casual content as well that
we can hopefully start,
you know, putting up on After
Dark and stuff like that.
More streams, hopefully.
- Yeah.
- I mean We haven't been
uploading much to After Dark
because we kind of want
to get everything set up
in the new studio and get
everything set up there.
So that it's way easier to make content.
- Also the new studio just
looks way better right now.
- We are extremely cramped in here.
- Yeah.
- Just wait, just wait
til you see Season Two.
- Season Two is going to be good. Yeah.
But anyways guys, that's,
probably going to do it for this.
Thank you for joining us on the
First Annual Trash Taste Awardw,
- and hope you hope you enjoyed it.
- Yeah, hopefully you guys enjoyed it.
Please look forward to more
content coming out soon.
So this, this is just the beginning.
We're going to keep going on from here.
- Yep.
- All right.
But hopefully you guys enjoyed it.
Have anything else to say?
- I don't have anything
else to say. It's over.
- It's over. Ggs.
- That's it lads. It's sad, you know?
I mean, I feel like
it's, it's bitter sweet.
You know, it's been a good year.
It's like, oh, okay, next year now.
- Yeah.
Enjoy the OVA episodes that are
going to come out after this.
- Going to be so weird.
- No, no, no.
Okay. Having already filmed some of them,
there were some banger
episodes coming out.
- The OVAs are just as good.
- Honestly. Honestly, if you think,
if you think Trash Taste
is peaked, you're wrong.
- Honestly, some of the ova are just-
(chef's kiss)
chef's kiss.
- They're just, they're
just, they're just,
they're just banging her episodes
before we get to our new-
- New place.
- Thank you for the year.
We'll see you next week.
Every week. We'll see
you every fucking week.
You can't get rid of us.
See you next week gamers.
- See you later guys.
- BYE!
(inspiring music)